thank you
Google is one of the world's leading
software and Technology developers every
year Google introduces new technical
discoveries and advancements that are
amazing and beneficial to people all
around the world
because more individuals are using Cloud
the Google Cloud platform has
experienced an increase in utilization
in recent years
a variety of Google cloud services for
Global consumers have been introduced in
response to the high demand of computing
resources
so on realizing the popularity and the
need for learning about Computing
resources of gcp I have brought a new
video of Simply learn on Google Cloud
in-depth tutorial 2022 in this video
I'll take you through crucial gcp
services and their in-depth Concepts
so without doing any further Ado let's
get started
but before diving deep into the concepts
we will first cover Basics starting with
understanding what is gcp followed by
the gcp tutorial in which we will
explore gcp services
and its infrastructure then we will have
a quick comparison between gcp AWS and
Azure along with hands-on experience
with gcp
then we will move on to gcp web hosting
and then we will understand Google
machine learning with proper
demonstration and at last we will look
into the essentials of Google Cloud
platform fundamentals
and how to exactly prepare for it
by the end of this video I can assure
you that all your gcp related Concepts
would have been clear
so for this training with me I have an
experienced gcp specialist together
we'll walk you through the different
crucial gcp Keynotes
so let's start with an exciting video on
Google Cloud in-depth tutorial 2022.
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon and never miss an update from
Simply run
good morning and good evening everyone
so welcome to this session on Google
Cloud platform my name is AJ and I'm an
instructor with simply learn and also
working as a big data and Cloud
architect for various clients across
globe in this session we learn about
Google Cloud platform wherein we will
learn about what is cloud computing why
Google Cloud platform what is gcp that
is Google Cloud platform Google Cloud
platform domains about a use case that
is Ferrero use case and also a quick
demo on using services from Google Cloud
platform so when we talk about Google
Cloud platform we also need to know what
is cloud computing so cloud computing is
the use of hardware and software
components to deliver a service to a
network users can access these files and
applications and services provided by a
cloud provider from any device that has
access to Internet in short cloud
computing is a way where cloud provider
provides access to different services
such as resources and when we talk about
resources here we talk about Computing
we talk about memory we talk about
processing power we talk about storage
and we also talk about different
Services which Cloud providers make
available for the users now that allows
us for automatic software integration
backup and restoring data unlimited
storage capacity having a reliable use
of different services and having a cost
efficient solution now we know that
cloud computing models there are
different service models so you have
platform as a service you have
infrastructure as a service and you have
have software as a service and these are
the prominent models which are offered
by different Cloud providers such as
Google Cloud such as Google you have
Amazon you have Azure and also some
organizations build their own private
clouds using open source openstack let's
focus more on Google Cloud platform and
what it has to offer and how it is
gaining popularity in the market with
different organizations which would want
to work on a cloud platform or which
would want to work on an infrastructure
which is modernized so when we talk
about cloud computing this is one of the
approach which organizations can take to
instantaneously benefit from
modernization using different Services
different platforms and also newer
Technologies for their various
requirements such as scalability or
dynamic businesses
before we get into Google Cloud platform
it is also good to understand where you
can find some useful resources about
Google Cloud platform and here you have
a website which is from your Google
Cloud so this is cloudacademy.com
Library slash Google and here you can
create a free account now that would
give you just seven days trial but that
has a lot of videos which talk about
your Google Cloud platform and
Essentials and it has various
certification related videos which you
can access and then after seven days
after you have tried you can obviously
go for a paid account where you can take
detailed learning from here now this is
your training Library which shows you a
different Cloud providers such as Amazon
Microsoft SEO gcp and then you have
various other topics which are specifics
to organization you can obviously look
at the pricing and you can also look at
resources which will give you a good
experience in learning from these videos
you can also create a free account which
I will walk you through later so you can
create a free account on
cloud.google.com now when I say free
account that basically means it allows
you to create an account and every user
who creates an account gets a 300 free
credit which can be used to practice
brush up your skills and also explore
and learn about different Google Cloud
products which are offered by Google
now coming back to our Google Cloud
platform let's understand why Google
Cloud platform so Google Cloud platform
is popular for many reasons now let us
see few of most important reasons why it
stands out
when you talk about pricing pricing is
one of the significant factors that make
Google Cloud Stand Out Among the other
Cloud providers
it offers a monthly pricing plan which
is billed according to monthly usage and
when we talk about billing here the
billing can be in hours it can be in
minutes and it can also be in seconds
there are different options when you
talk about your pricing which can be
found from your Google Cloud web page
now pricing could be based on preemptive
machines pricing could be based on
reserved instances or reserved resources
I'll show you the link where you can
find more details on pricing part of it
so Google Cloud really has various
pricing options which help customers in
their different requirements whether
they would go for any of the service
models such as infrastructure as a
service platform as a service or even
software as a service one more
attractive thing about Google Cloud
pricing is that it provides committed
use discounts
for example under this scheme you can
purchase a specific amount of virtual
CPU cores and memory for up to 57
discount off regular prices if you
commit usage for either one or three
years now this is just one option there
are various such options which you can
learn about from the Google clouds page
and that really suits different
customers for their different
requirements
now when we talk about speed we don't
need to really challenge this aspect
when it comes to Google services so
Google provides it's Google cloud and
Google app customer speed up to 10
terabytes because of its faster cable
system there are different kind of
machines which can be used if you are
talking about computation if you are
talking about memory hungry applications
or even storage intensive workloads okay
all in all speed is one of the defining
characteristics of Google cloud services
the cable has connections over us West
course main cities in Japan and even
major hubs in Asia this speed enhances
performances and leads to customer
satisfaction now when we talk about
customers any or every customer would
prefer to have low latency High
throughput Based Services they would
want to use higher speeds to process
their data in as less time as possible
Google provides a low latency Network
infrastructure in fact you can say that
when you are using Google cloud services
you are using the services from the same
infrastructure which Google uses for its
popular services such as Google search
or even YouTube which is one of the
second largest repository which can be
accessed for videos now when we talk
about Big Data big data is data which is
very complex has lot of other
characteristics such as your volume you
have velocity you have variety you have
velocity validity volatility virility
and so on so if an organization has is
working on Big Data Google Cloud can be
a better choice because Google has many
Innovative tools for cloud warehousing
for example such as bigquery and even
real-time data processing tools such as
data flow bigquery is a data warehouse
that allows massive processing of data
at high speeds basically working on your
structured data Google also has launched
some new machine learning from
artificial intelligence tools now there
are various other services which we can
which we can use from Google Cloud
platform but let's understand what is
Google Cloud platform and what are some
of the services even the services which
are not less tested here can be found in
your console from Google Cloud so what
is Google Cloud platform gcp it is a set
of Cloud Computing Services provided by
Google that runs on the same
infrastructure as I mentioned that
Google uses for its end user products
like YouTube Gmail and even Google
search the various set of services
offered by Google Cloud platform are so
you have Services which are specific to
Computing requirements and again in
Computing you have various different
options available you have machines
which are compute optimized machines
which are memory optimized machines
which are storage optimized and also we
have certain machines such as preemptif
which basically means that you could get
a machine to work on at a far lesser
price than any other machine but when we
talk about preemptive these are the
machines which can be requested on
demand and they can be taken back by
Google at any time you have networking
related Services which can be very
useful when you are setting up your
applications or your services across
Globe you also have different Services
which are specific to machine learning
and organizations which would be
interested in working on machine
learning or artificial intelligence
would be really interested in using
these Services there are also innovative
solutions to work on big data and Big
Data related Technologies now when we
talk about Google Cloud platform domains
so we can break down these Services into
specifics such as you have compute now
the compute service allows for computing
and hosting the cloud
now when you talk about Computing here
there are different services such as app
engine you have compute engine you have
kubernetes you have Cloud functions and
Cloud run when you talk about storage
and database so the storage and database
service allows application to store
media files backups or other file like
objects now various Services Under This
are as follows you have cloud storage
Cloud SQL Cloud bigtable for
unstructured data you have Cloud spanner
cloud data store persistent disks and
Cloud memory store when we talk about
networking the networking service allows
us to load balanced traffic across
resources now as I mentioned earlier
resources could be your different
resources which you would be using from
a cloud platform such as your devices
your instances memory optimize or CPU
optimized instances us or other
resources creating DNS records and much
more so various Services Under This are
VPC that stands for virtual private
Cloud you have Cloud load balancing
Cloud armor Cloud CDN you have Cloud
interconnect DNS and network service
tiers when we talk about the big data
service this allows us to process and
query big data in Cloud now various
Services under these are as follows you
have bigquery cloud cloud data proc
Cloud composer cloud data lab cloud data
prep Cloud Pub sub which is publishing
subscribing system you have cloud data
studio now you also have the developer
tools and developer Tools service
includes tools related to development of
an application now various Services
under these are as follows that is you
have Cloud SDK software development kit
you have deployment manager Cloud Source
Repository and Cloud test lab when we
talk about identity and security which
is one of the primary concerns for any
organization or any user who would be
interested in using a cloud platform
Google Cloud really has taken care of
this so when you talk about identity and
security domain this deals with Security
Services now various Services here are
Cloud identity you have identity and
access management that is cloud IAM you
have identity aware proxies you have
cloud data loss prevention API security
key enforcement Key Management Service
and many more you also have cloud
services which are related to internet
of things so very much would be used by
organizations who would be working on
iot devices or the data generated by
these devices so various Services here
are Cloud iot Core you have Edge TPU and
Cloud iot also when we talk about Cloud
AI that is artificial intelligence this
comprises of services related to machine
learning and much more so you have Cloud
Auto ml Cloud TPU Cloud machine learning
engine job Discovery dialogue flow
Enterprise natural language Cloud text
to speech and much more
if you would be interested in Services
related to API platform then there are
different Services Under This category
or this domain so you have Maps platform
you have APG API platform monetization
developer portal analytics that is API
analytics APG sends Cloud endpoints and
service infrastructure so these are some
of the listing of services under each
Cloud platform domain now let's look at
Ferrero use case and let's also
understand what was done here so Ferrero
is one of the famous chocolate and ranks
third among worldwide chocolate and
confectionary producers it was found in
1946 in Italy I'm sure you would have
seen the Ferrero chocolates when you
would have gone out to buy some
chocolates so the challenges here was
that Ferrero as we know is sold in every
supermarket and is known for its quality
once the prisoners grew some issues
arose right and that's what happens when
the business grows you have issues
popping up which could be related to the
volume of data the speed with which the
data is getting generated the variety of
data and also looking at your platforms
which support different Dynamic
applications or your scalability
requirements performance requirements
and so on
so it needed data storage processing and
Analysis system for a wide customer
database
there was a huge gap between the company
and the people who bought its goods
because the company relied on data given
sales outlets now that's one of the
challenge Ferrero wanted to create a
digital ecosystem where there was a
point of contact with its customers and
also a foundation for an Innovative
data-driven marketing strategy what was
the solution here so one of the service
of cloud platforms or Google Cloud
platform is bigquery and this was an
answer to ferrero's challenges since it
was capable of hyper fast and efficient
data analysis as a solution now as I
mentioned bigquery is a data warehouse
which allows you to store structured
data now this could directly be used as
a service where you could store in any
amount of data and you would not be
paying for storage so there are
different pricing models and for data up
to one terabytes you would not be
charged anything and if you would be
accessing the data that is reading the
data or processing the data from
bigquery that's where the pricing model
kicks in
Now using Google Cloud's bigquery
business analysts of Ferrero were able
to store and analyze massive data sets
in a very reliable fast and affordable
manner
consumer behavior and sales pattern data
reports were easy to build and automate
and the analysis also followed Ferrero
to adopt advertising across various
marketing channels to serve the customer
needs in a better way what was the
result
they could divide their database into
real-time actionable consumer clusters
to generate more accurate user profiles
Ferrero was also able to personalize its
marketing strategies to match the user
needs
now Google Cloud platform completely
tailored the website mobile content and
advertising and created a very cost
effective media by strategy now these
were some Basics on Google Cloud now as
I said you can always find lot of
details about pricing about services and
also all the services are accessible in
your free trial account now let me just
walk you through here so one is you
could always find details on
documentation on each of these services
so if I would click on getting started
you have quick start which basically
shows you short tutorials you have
trainings and you have also
certifications now if we click on quick
start now that takes me to this page
which shows me
quick starts or if you would want to
understand about different projects if
you would want to look into the
documentation of creating a Linux
virtual machine or storing a file and
sharing it deploying a container Docker
container image and so on so you have a
lot of quick starts here you can also
look at Cloud minute
on the same page on the right side you
have docs and once you click on that it
takes you to these links now this shows
you build Solutions which shows your top
use cases best practices all the
solutions it's always good to learn from
these use cases which are available and
here you have different feature products
and all the different Services which
Google Cloud offers now you can click on
featured products and that basically
shows you a list of these products now
here we have all the solutions which you
can look at architecture database
Enterprise level big data and Analysis
gaming related internet of things and so
on now if you go down here it shows you
featured products and that shows you
some of the important products such as
compute engine which is belonging to the
compute domain you have Cloud run you
have anthos which is for migration and
basically Cloud adoption when
organizations would want to move from
on-premise to cloud-based Solutions you
have Vision AI you have cloud storage
now that basically allows you to store
any kind of data whether that's an
object so this is acting as an object
storage you have Cloud SQL which is
basically a ready to use service where
you would be using MySQL postgres or any
other SQL Server database Services you
have bigquery which is a data warehouse
which basically allows you to store your
structured data and then you have your
AI and machine learning related products
so you have automl Vision AI video AI
text to speech speech to text and so on
now you also have different platform
accelerators which can be used and in
any of these cases for example if I
would click on compute engine which is a
featured product from Google Cloud now
that shows you basically your quick
starts using your Linux machines how-to
guides which tells you completely
working on a VM instance
or working on storage working on
persistent disks and so on and it shows
you the documentation here now you also
have products and pricing option which
you can see for GCB pricing and you
could straight away go to the pricing
you could be looking at Solutions which
talks about infrastructure modernization
now this is something which
organizations are interested in when
they would want to move from their
on-premise solution to your Google Cloud
now here I can say for example I click
on infrastructure modernization you can
always find some case studies what are
the different solutions we have here
right when you talk about Google Cloud
so you can always click on see Solutions
and you can look at VM migration or sap
Cloud right by Google Cloud what it can
be used for VMware as a service or HPC
that is high performance Computing and
about these services we will learn in
detail later now I can go back on the
same page where I was clicking on the
services so you have quick starts you
have how-to guides you have deep
understanding of different concepts
right and here if I click on all how to
guides so that shows me what are the
different ways in which you can work
with compute engine and working with
different instances although it's quite
exhaustive content but then if you
follow steady D then you can learn a lot
about Google Cloud now here I can just
go back so this is just giving you some
idea on the different products which are
available from Google Cloud looking into
different sections finding right
documentation here right and you can
always look into each one of these in
detail for each product which Google
Cloud offers
now if we scroll down we could see all
the options or all the domains which we
see here right let me just go back
because we got into Solutions now we
have quick starts right and then you can
basically scroll all the way down to
look at Cloud SDK which can be set up on
your Windows machine like I have set it
up on my Windows machine plus when you
use Google console you have a GUI which
I'll show you in a couple of minutes and
also a cloud shell where you can use
your command line options to work with
Google Cloud platform you have Cloud
console which is nothing but your GUI to
access your resources now you can also
look at in-depth tutorials pricing and
you have different other options so
let's just click on pricing here and
then we have your price list which
basically gives you details of different
services what are available and what are
the services or what are the prices so
for example if I click on compute engine
right and this shows me the pricing
aspect of compute engine which belongs
to compute domain and here you can see
you have VM instance pricing you have
networking pricing sold tenant nodes
which are specific to particular
organizations or if organizations would
want to have dedicated nodes you have
GPU based pricing right so General
processing units you have disk and image
pricing and you can click on any of the
links and you can see pricing which also
shows you your different kind of machine
types so here you have different kind of
machine types which says N1 N2 n2d E2
you have memory optimized machine types
you have compute optimized you have
premium images and you can basically
look at all the categories you can look
at disk pricing which involves your
persistent disk pricing for ssds or sdds
what are the kind of images what are the
different network Services right and you
can always look at your machine types
you can choose a particular region right
there is the concept of region and
availability zones here and as per
region you could look at the prices
you can also look at standard prices you
could be looking for what are the free
tier machines if I'm specifically
looking for VM instance pricing I can
click on this one and that takes me to
the VM instance pricing what is the
billing module what is the instance
uptime what is the resource base pricing
and then you can also look at different
kind of discounts such as sustained use
discounts committed use discounts
discounts from preemptable VM instances
and so on and this is how you can be
looking at pricing for all different
resources and you can choose the
resource which you are interested in and
then look for the pricing benchmarks
reservations if you would want to use
and you would want to benefit if you
would want to look at what are the
quotas and limits and so on so please
explore this link and you can find lot
of information when it comes to
technical options looking at different
Google Cloud products which we briefly
discussed when it comes to domains and
what each product can be used for you
can always come back to the main page
where I was showing you different
Services we went into pricing straight
away right now you can always come back
to this page on your cloud.google.com
and then you have your Solutions
which talks about different products
right and you can click on these or you
can look into technical documentation so
this talks about your different featured
Solutions infrastructure Solutions you
have data center migration related and
so on so I could be talking more and
more about Google Cloud platform it's a
ocean it's a huge chunk of different
services for different organizational
requirements so look into this link and
also what you can do is create a account
on Gmail I mean you could create a free
account or you could go to
cloud.google.com and then you could
create a free account like I have
created here and I can just click on
Console now that's my GUI or Google
Cloud console which basically allows me
to work with Google Cloud now there are
a lot of options here by default when
you create an account now in my case on
the top it says it's a free trial
account I have three hundred dollars
credit and out of that 251 dollars is
left and 237 days out of a year are left
for my account now here I can basically
see the project right and by default we
can create an project or by default
there is a project existing for any user
so when you log in it creates a
particular project and you could create
a new project and project would be to
dedicate your different services or
different resources per different
project so this is your dashboard which
basically shows your project which shows
you a project number and a project ID
which is always unique now you can click
on this and this if you would want you
can hide this information you can also
look into the documentation part of it
then it shows you the different services
or a graphical information of services
which you might have used in past so you
have compute engine which shows you how
much percentage of CPU was used you can
always go to compute engine as a service
you can look at your Google route
platform status and look at the Google
Cloud status now this is billing now
since this shows me the billing period
for April month and I can always look at
detailed charges I can look at reporting
I can look at different apis which
Google offers and for your different
kind of work you can always go to the
API overview or the API link and enable
or disable any API now once you enable
or disable any API then you can use that
so you have new section you have
documentation and you have getting
started guides which tells you how to
work or enable different apis if you
would want to deploy a pre-built
solution at Dynamic logging monitoring
errors deploying a Hello World app and
so on now this is your dashboard I can
click on activity and that would show me
what kind of activity I would have done
in my cloud platform I can always choose
the kind of activities by saying
activity type I can choose the resources
now it shows me that I created some VM
instances I deleted them I updated some
metadata I basically worked on instances
I changed some firewall rules here I
have then also worked on some other
services or apis so I created some
buckets which is for object storage and
again I have been working with some
instances and creating some firewall
rules here I have granted some
permissions I am setting up a policy
right so this activity gives me a
history of what things I have done over
past couple of months while working on
Google Cloud platform now
on the top left corner you have the
hamburger menu which you can click on
this so that's your navigation menu and
when you click on this this shows you
home it takes you to the marketplace it
specifically takes you to billing you
can always look at apis and services so
here in API Services I can pretty much
go to a dashboard and I can see a report
on the traffic or errors or latency and
the kind of apis which are available so
you have compute engine API you have
bigquery API bigquery data transfer API
bigquery storage cloud data proc so
these are some of the apis or Services
I've used in past might be I was
evaluating a product might be I was
using a particular product so you have
whenever you would want to use a
particular service from Google Cloud
platform you would be enabling these
apis so here we see some apis for data
proc you have logging monitoring you
have have resource manager API you have
Cloud SQL which allows you to directly
use MySQL or postgres you have cloud
storage right and so many apis so if I
would want to enable a particular API
which is not right now required but then
it's good to know you can always click
on this one you can search for an API so
for example if I would say data proc
right and that shows me the cloud data
proc API which manages Hadoop based
clusters and jobs on Google Cloud
platform so I can spin up a Hadoop
cluster and I can start running some
jobs on a Hadoop cluster on demand and
as I'm done with it I can just get rid
of it so this is an API which I would
have to enable and then for every
particular service you also have an
admin API which you would enable
now going back so coming out from this
API Library I got into API and services
now there is you can look into the
library you can look at credentials and
you can also look at different time
intervals for which you can see the
usage of your different apis now going
back to the menu you have support
wherein you can always reach out to the
Google support team if you are using a
paid version even with free trial you
can try to reach out and you will find
someone to help but it is always good
when you have a billing cycle reaching
out the customer care you have identity
access management and admin and this is
required when you're working with
different apis or Services when you
would want to have relevant access you
have getting started you have security
related options you have anthos which is
mainly for migration now here you can
look at your different domains such as
which we discussed so you have of
compute and in compute you have
different services so you have app
engine you have compute engine
kubernetes you have Cloud functions and
Cloud run you can look into the storage
aspect which shows you bit table which
is usually and mainly for your
unstructured data big table which is
something which gave rise to popular
nosql databases like edgebase and
Cassandra you have data store which can
be used you have firestore file store
storage which can be used to put in data
of any kinds you have SQL for structured
data you have spanner as a service you
have memory store and you have data
transfer now when it comes to the
networking domain you have all these
services such as VPC virtual private
network network related services for
your load balancing for using a
cloud-based DNS or Cloud defined Network
you have hybrid connectivity network
service tiers security and intelligence
then you have other options for your
operations which can be used and here
you have different other tools which can
be used such as Cloud build you have
Cloud tasks containers registry
deployment manager and many more big
data specific you have the services here
so you have data proc which can be used
to spin up your clusters you have
published subscribe messaging systems
such as now Kafka which you might have
heard of originates its idea from here
so Pub sub you have data flow you have
iot core bigquery which is a data
warehouse package or data warehousing
solution from Google Cloud now then you
have your artificial intelligence
related services and other Google
Solutions so you can always find a huge
list of services or you can say at high
level Solutions offered by Google cloud
and we can use these to basically test
some of the solutions use them and work
on them so I'll give you a quick demo on
different Services which can be used
here from your Google Cloud platform now
this is your Google Cloud platform and
this is your console now this also gives
you a cloud shell which can be activated
so that you can work from command line
and you can always find a lot of
documentation on that so you can also
set up your Cloud shell that is SDK on
your Windows machine and if you have set
it up then basically you could be doing
something like gcloud right if the cloud
has been set up so in my case I had set
up the cloud SDK and basically I can get
into that by looking at what path I have
set up so Cloud SDK and then I can be
using it from my Windows machine as per
my comfort I can also activate the cloud
shell here which will basically open up
a terminal and at any point of time you
can open up this one Cloud cell in a
different window it is preparing the
cloud shell where it will by default set
up your project it will set up the
metadata and now I am logged into my
Google Cloud account from command line
and here I can basically use gcloud
right and that basically shows you the
different options which are available
which you can be using so if you would
want to use a particular service you can
also try giving a help and that shows
you how do you manage your Google Cloud
platform right so you have different
options for billing to work with your
different services and basically you
could be working on Google Cloud using
this Cloud shell from your command line
usually for people who are learning old
cloud in the beginning it is always good
to go for console and use your different
services from here in an easier way but
as I said you can always use the command
line for example if I would just go
ahead and type gcloud create instances
and that will directly take me to the
cloud console documentation which shows
you different options which you can use
to work with instances so I could do a
gcloud compute instances create and then
I can give my instance name and so on
and I'll show you some examples on that
so you can be using your Cloud console
right that is your Cloud shell and you
can straight away start working from
command line however I would suggest
using console in the beginning and when
you are well experienced then you can
start using Cloud cell to do things from
command line and when you are fully
experienced you can always switch and
certain things are usually useful or
easier when done from command line and
some are easier when you do it from the
console and you can use any one of these
options now we can go to Google Cloud
console now as of now I can close this
one I still have my cloud cell open if I
would want to look into it I can click
on this one and I can straight away go
to compute and engine where I would want
to work on creating some instances on
Google Cloud platform using the compute
engine service and then basically
connecting to those instances and
basically trying out some basic things
so you can click on VM instances and
then once this comes up I can always
create some instances now if you see
here I have some instances already
created right and I can continue working
on those I can create new instances I
can use different options while creating
instances and I'll show you that in a
demo in quick seconds so let's have a
quick demo on setting up gcp instances
now before that let's have a quick recap
so when you talk about instance or a
virtual machine it is hosted on Google's
infrastructure right and you can create
your Google Cloud instance using this
Google Cloud console that is by clicking
on this and then going to compute engine
and clicking on VM instances now you can
also do that from Google Cloud command
line tool that is cloud shell and you
can be doing that using compute engine
API so compute engine instances can run
the public images for Linux or Windows
servers that Google provides you also
have option of creating or using custom
images that you can create and import
from your existing systems you can
deploy Docker containers which are
automatically launched on instance
running containers optimized OS now when
you talk about instances and projects
always remember that in each instance
belongs to a Google Cloud console
project and a project can have one or
more instances
when you talk about instances and
storage options each instance has a
small boot persistent disk which I will
show you in further screens that
contains the OS you can add more storage
space if needed
and when you talk about instances and
network a project can have up to five
VPC networks so VPC network is virtual
private networks wherein you can virtual
private Cloud networks where you can
have your resources within your own
subnet and each instance belongs to one
VPC Network now instances in same
network can communicate with each other
through local area network protocol an
instance uses internet to communicate
within any machine so that could be
virtual physical or outside its own
network when you talk about instances
and containers you should remember that
compute engine instances support a
declarative method for launching your
application using containers now you can
create a VM instance or a VM instance
template you can provide a Docker image
and launch the configuration
so there are different ways in which you
can create these instances and once you
create these instances you can say for
example you're creating a Linux instance
you can associate SSH keys with your
Google account or your G Suite account
and then manage your admin non-admin
access to the instance using IM roles if
you connect to your instance using
gcloud or SSH from console which we will
see later compute engine can generate
SSH keys for you and apply that to your
Google cloud or G Suite account now what
we can do is we can see how we can
create your Google Cloud instances from
your console or from the command line
let's have a look in creating instances
using GCB console now that we have
learned on some basics of Google Cloud
platform what are the different Services
what are different domains basically
looking at your Google Cloud console or
even Cloud Shell let's go ahead and
create some VM instances now that's from
your compute engine service and let's
try connecting to these instances and
see how this works let's also see what
are the different options which are
available when you would want to create
the virtual machine instances here so
when you click on your drop down from
the top left and choose compute engine
so it brings you to this page so I can
show that again so you can click on
compute engine click on VM instances and
that basically brings you to this page
now here it tells you compute engine
lets you use Virtual machines that run
on Google's infrastructure so we can
create micro VMS or large instances
running different distributions of Linux
or Windows using standard images that is
public images and you can also have your
own image so let's create a VM instance
by clicking on create
now that's basically helping me to
create an instance here so it shows me
the instance name I can give it
something so let me say C1 now I can add
labels so what is label it basically
allows you to organize your project add
arbitrary labels as key value pairs to
your resources this so this is basically
categorizing your labels and projects if
you have multiple projects now remember
if you have your Cloud console and if
you have created your free trial account
it will allow you to do these things if
not you may have to go back to the
billing section and see if the billing
is enabled which also means that when
you are creating your Google Cloud
account it will ask you to clean your
credit card details but they do not
charge anything or they might charge
might be one dollar or one rupee
depending on your location and that's
also refunded but that's just to verify
your card now once I've given the name I
can choose a region so I would basically
choose Europe since I'm in Europe I
would be clicking on Europe West 3 and
here I can choose an availability Zone
availability zone is basically to make
your services or instances or any other
resources highly available so you can
choose one of the availability zones now
I would choose save S3 now this one we
can scroll down and here it says machine
configurations you have general purpose
machines you have memory optimized
machines which is M1 series and you can
always go back to the Google Cloud page
and see what a particular kind of
machine specializes in so I would click
on General's purpose and in general
purpose you have different categories so
you have N1 which is powered by Intel
Skylake CPU platform or you have E2
which is CPU platform selected selection
based on availability so let's have N1
selected now this one shows me the
machine type and if you are using your
free tier account then you can start
with correcting a micro machine which is
one virtual CPU core you can go for a G1
small which is one virtual CPU core and
1.7 GB Ram you can even go up to a
high-end machine and then you can
basically see if you are using a free
account how many of these machines you
can use if I would be selecting eight
virtual CPU cores and 32 gigabyte of
memory then it would allow me to create
at least two instances by this
configuration we will use N1 standard
which is one virtual CPU core 3.75 GB
memory now then we can also deploy a
container image to this VM instance if
you would be interested in deploying a
container image let's not get into that
right now here it shows you the port
disk and it shows you dbn gnu9 the next
nine what I would do is I can go for
this distribution or I can choose a
Linux distribution of my choice so here
you have public images you have custom
images you also have snapshots if you
have created backup of your previous
images here I can choose for example
Ubuntu and then I can choose a
particular version so let's go for
Ubuntu 18.04 you can go for the latest
one also 18.04 would be good enough and
here it tells me what is a boot disk so
you have ssds or you have standard
persistent disks now ssds are little
expensive in comparison to your standard
persistent disks or your sdds but then
ssds are faster so as of now we can
choose standard persistent disk as it is
and we can let the gigabyte be 10 now
depending on your requirement you can
increase this you can even add disks
later that's not a problem click on
select now here I have access Scopes so
here I will say allow default access you
can also set access for each API or you
can give full access to all Cloud apis
so that based on your requirement you
can any time change later also we will
also say allow HTTP traffic and we can
also choose allow https traffic that
basically allows me to access this
machine or Services which are HTTP based
accessible from this machine now I can
just click on create however it would be
good to basically enable connectivity to
this machine now we can do that in
different ways one is when you bring up
your machine it will have an SSH access
which you can log in from the cloud
platform here itself or what you can do
is you can create a private and a public
key using some softwares like putty or
puttygen so for example if you do not
have that on your machine you can
download you can just type in download
putty that takes you to the putty.org
page and here you can click on download
putty and scroll down which shows you
for your 64-bit machine which I have in
my case you can download putty.exe which
is basically your SSH internet client to
connect to your machines you can also
use putty gen which will be allowing you
to create a private and a public key
which I have done in my case let me show
you how so what you can do is you can go
to puttygen to begin with and here you
can click on generate now then to have
this key generated just move your cursor
on the top here in the empty space and
that creates your key you can give it a
name so for example let's give a
username I would give hdu now I can give
a password for this one so let me give a
simple password
and what I can also do is I can copy
this public key from here and for my
later usage I can just keep it in my
notepad file which I can use later and
I'll show you when so now we can save
this private key and this will basically
allow me to save my private key I can
choose desktop and I can give it a name
so let's say new key new key and that
will be getting saved in a DOT PPK file
so let's save it and that's done so we
also have our public key and we have
saved our private key now we know that
when you would want to connect using SSH
you need your private keys to the client
and public key also has to be existing
so let's take this public key so let's
do a control a I'm going to copy this
and I'm going to come back to my Google
Cloud console and here you can click on
security so you can click on the
security tab here here scroll down and
just give your public key once you give
that it resolves and shows you the name
and this is good enough so that I can
use my SSH client to connect to this
machine I can click on Create and this
will basically create my VM instance it
will take some time and then your
instance will have an internal IP which
will show up here external IP and it
will also show you options to connect to
these machines so this is my internal IP
this is my external IB which I can use
to connect from a client I can easily
connect from the option here which says
SSH and I can say open in a browser
window I can even open this in a custom
Port I can look at the gcloud command
which you can give from cloud shell or
you can use another SSH so let's first
do a open in browser window and let's
see if this connects so we can easily
connect to our instance the Ubuntu 18
instance which I just set up here easily
in couple of seconds now this is trying
to establish a connection using your SSH
keys and when you do that it also
basically brings up this web browser so
I'm already connected it shows my
username which is my cloud account
username and I have been connected to
this machine here using SSH it did not
ask me for any password and basically
now I can just check what do I have in
my Linux file system right and I can
anytime login as root by doing a sudo Su
for example let's try installing a
package and I can say aptkit install Vim
or at get install wget or aptkit install
open SSH and all these packages are
already existing so not an issue now I
can start using this instance I can just
look at the disk what is available okay
now we gave an on 10 gigabyte out of
which we see 8.3 gigabyte here for the
dev sda1 and then 1.8 gigabyte available
and you can continue using this machine
this was the easiest way of connecting
to a VM instance using SSH
now what we can also do is I can just
leave this and I will now try to connect
using an external SSH client right and
here you can copy the public IP so when
you want to connect to an instance you
will have to get the public IP also
remember that if you select and stop
this machine which will stop your
billing counter and if you start it
again the internal IP will remain same
but the external IP is the one which
will change
I can obviously select this machine
anytime and I can do a cleanup and I can
delete it I can do a start of the
machine if it is stopped and I can even
import the virtual machine to be used
later so there are different options
which you can always use so this is my
instance and if you would want to look
at the details click on this one C1 and
that should basically allow you to look
at the details so it shows you what is
the instance ID what is the machine type
is it reservation specific what is the
CPU platform what's the zone and all the
other details at any point of time if
you would want to edit you can always
click on edit and you can change the
details as you need now you can also
look at the equivalent rest command to
basically use the rest API to connect to
this instance for now I have copied the
public IP and I would want to connect it
using putty so let's go in here and
let's give the hostname so I can give
Ubuntu I can give my IP address so
that's in my session now I will click on
SSH I would go into authentication I'll
click on browse and this is where I need
to choose the PPK file so this is the
one which we created new key let's
select this
and then I can come back to session I
can even save this and I can call it as
my instance one let's save it and you
can create any number of instances so
you see I have created different
instances here for my Google cloud or
Amazon related instances and I can click
on open it says the service host key is
not cached in the registry that's fine
just click on yes
and basically it says no authentication
method supported now this could be
because we have not enabled your SSH
access so let's look at that so now
let's see if we were trying to connect
using putty what was the issue here so
if I go back to my putty select my
instance load it it says Port 22 I am
giving the username which is Ubuntu or
sorry that's the wrong username we gave
and that might be the reason we had set
up the user as sdu so let's save this
again and now let's try connecting to
this one and it asks for my password and
you are able to connect this right now
if there was any other issue related to
network connectivity then we could look
at the rules the inbound and outbound
rules which allow us to look into the
machine now we are connected to our
machine here using hdu user I can log in
as root and I can continue working so
not only from the SSH within the cloud
console but you can use an external SSH
client and connect to your machine so
this is your Ubuntu machine and we can
basically look at the space and that
basically confirms we are connecting to
the same machine which shows 8.3
gigabytes here and 1.8 gigabytes here
which we were seeing from the ssh in the
browser now let's close this and let's
go back to our instance page now here
you can always look at the network
details and this will show you your
different kind of rules that is ingress
or egress rules which basically allows
to connect to this machine from an
external network or for this machine to
connect to an external network so here
we have different firewall rules which
shows default allow HTTP that's your
Ingress Rule and it tells you apply to
all it shows me what are the IP ranges
where I can specifically give the ipf my
machine it shows the protocols it shows
what are the different ports which you
have used for these services for example
RDP or SSH which shows 22 you have icmp
HTTP and https now anytime if you would
want to make a change to these rules
that can be done by going into your
network details and say for example you
would want to work on firewall rules so
we have these firewall rules here you
can click on this one so right now we
are looking into the network domain and
we are looking into VPC Network right
and this shows me what are the different
rules we have now if I would want to
create a different firewall rule for a
different protocol I can always click on
create firewall rule I can give it a
name okay I can say what if you would
want to turn on the firewall logs you
can basically say what is the kind of
traffic so Ingress applies to incoming
traffic and egress applies to outgoing
traffic and you can then basically
choose what are the IP ranges from where
you want that connection to be coming in
or two going out you can choose a
particular protocol you can give a
protocol here with comma separated
values and you can create a firewall
rule so this might be required depending
on the services which you are running
wherein you might want to enable your
access to your machine from an external
service or to an external service so you
can always go to network details from
here you can then go into firewall rules
create a firewall rule apply that to
your instance and restart your instance
so as of now we don't need to create any
network details here because my Ingress
or egress rules are already available
right now I can basically then have my
instance stopped and removed so I can
just do a stop or since this is running
the ideal wave would be to do a stop I
could also do a reset now what does
reset do reset does not basically delete
the machine what it does is it does a
cleanup of the machine and it brings it
to the initial state so sometimes we
might have installed certain things on
our machine we would want to clean them
up and at that time reset can be useful
I can basically click on delete right
and I can select this and I can way
clean up and this is good always when
you are using a free trial account try
to use different Services play around
with them and then you can clean up so
that you do not waste your free billing
credit right and you can use it for
Meaningful stuff now I have clicked on
delete and within few seconds my
instance which I had created will be
deleted also to remember is if you are
creating multiple instances then you can
connect from one machine to other
machine using SSH by using the private
file so for that we can learn in detail
later so this is just a simple example
of using your compute engine creating
your instances connecting to it from an
internal SSH or from an external SSH
client such as putty where you have
already created your private and public
Keys now I can click on the browser here
and then I can basically come out and I
can basically be looking into any
particular service so we just looked
into compute engine right you have
different other options you have
instance groups you have instance
templates for example let's click on
instance templates here and that
basically shows you that you don't have
any instance template and this basically
facilitates say for example you are
working as a admin and you would want to
create an instance template so that
using that you can describe a VM
instance and then you can basically use
this template to create different
instances you can go for soul tenant
nodes you can look for machine images
you can also look at your disks you can
create a snapshots and you can look at
different options here now let's come
back here and let's click on home and
that should take you back to your home
page which basically shows you if a
particular API which you have used
recently which shows me in the graph
here so I can go to the api's overview
right and that that basically shows me
if there were any errors if I was using
the compute engine API to basically
create a VM instance and that's why we
were seeing some spike in the graph so
this is a quick demo of using your
compute engine service provided by
Google Cloud wherein you can create VM
instances and use those VM instances for
your application installation for any
other purpose now that we have seen how
you use your Cloud console to create an
instance and also clean it up let's also
understand how you can do using your
command line options and let's see what
it takes or what are the different
commands which you can use to create
your instances
now you can always when when you're
creating an instance you can use compute
engine which Provisions resources to
start the instance so instance basically
has different states which we can see
when we are creating the instance so you
basically start the instance instance
moves into staging that is prepared for
your first boot finally it boots up and
then it moves into running so when you
look at instant states which we will
create instance in C it will basically
have different states such as
provisioning where resources are being
allocated for instance but instance is
not yet running then it goes into
staging where resources have been
acquired and instance is being prepared
for your first boot then instance is
booting up and running and if you are
stopping an instance it goes into being
stop status and it would be moved to the
terminated option you can also do a
repairing of instance and finally you
can terminate your instance or clean it
up by stopping and then deleting it now
when you say stopping and resetting an
instance you can stop the instance as I
showed earlier if you no longer need it
but if you need for future use you can
just use the reset option which will
basically wipe the content tense of
instance or any application State and
then finally you can stop it and have it
terminated now when you would want to do
that using your Cloud console or we have
seen the options now let's also see from
the command line tool how you can do it
so here I have the cloud cell which I
brought up from here and I basically
opened it in a new window so command
line tool enables you to easily manage
your compute engine resources in a
friendlier format than using your
compute engine API now gcloud which is
part of cloud SDK is the main command
here and then you can always auto
complete the different options here so
when you would want to create or work on
gcloud you can just type in gcloud here
and then for example I could just say
help to see different options of gcloud
which will show me the different options
which you can use here now we would be
interested in compute instances so I
could also do a g Cloud compute
compute instances and then I can
basically say create and then I can do a
help now that should show me different
options which work with gcloud compute
instances create command which is
expecting an instance name so your
Google Cloud SDK which we can set up on
our Windows machine or even on your
Linux machine is set of tools that helps
you to manage resources and applications
hosted on your gcp that is your Google
Cloud platform now here you have options
such as gcloud which I'm showing you
right now you have Gs util and then you
have BQ so that also can be used so you
can set up a Google Cloud compute if
using gcloud now what we can do is if we
are setting up our SDK on our Windows
machine then we would have to do a
gcloud init which basically initializes
your configurations for GE cloud
now here we are using a cloud shell
which was started from the console and
we don't have to basically give your
gcloud init command because it's already
initialized now you can always look at
your default Zone you can look at your
region what is being used all those
things are coming from the metadata
which is being used so for example I
could be looking at the metadata for my
particular project by just doing a g
cloud and then I can say compute and I
would be interested in Project info so I
can just do a project minus info and
then I can do it describe and then I
need my project ID so I can say minus
minus project and I can get my project
ID from here so you can click on this
one and that's my project ID so I can
click on this one and here I can just do
a right click and if it does not paste
then you can do a control V and then I
can try to look at my project info so
this basically will give me the metadata
which is by default set and we can
always look at what are the regions or
what is the Zone which has been set so
if it has been set so I'm looking at my
details it is showing me my SSH keys and
then it can be using your default region
and your default available zones it also
shows my username and other details so
this is basically to look at the
metadata which is available now at any
point of time I can basically say add
metadata I can basically choose metadata
option and I can say my default region
should be Europe which I was choosing
earlier so I can just bring up this
command again and what I can do is I can
say here where I have gcloud compute
project info where I did a describe
earlier now what I can also do is I can
just say add metadata
and then I can specify what is the
metadata I would be interested in adding
I can then say Google compute
default
region
and then I can basically give a region
for example Europe and then I can say
West 3
and if you are not well experienced you
can always do it from console or you can
be doing it from here so I'm giving
Google Cloud compute Google compute
default region then I can also give a
Google compute default Zone
and then I can pass in a value for
default zone so I can say Europe West 3
and then basically I can give an
availability zone so if it is basically
giving me some error where I'm trying to
pass in these values so I can just give
it this way and then it basically says
that if you can look into particular
help to see what is the command which
you would have to do now I can basically
do a g Cloud init here initial
configuration and this basically says
that it is initializing my default
configuration it says re-initialize this
configuration from cloud shell you want
to create a new configuration so if I
had updated my metadata then basically I
could just do a cloud in it and I could
be re-initializing my default
configuration or properties which I have
passed question so as of now I will not
activate or change the default region
let's go for a simple way in which you
can create your compute engine so for
example I'll just say one and it is
reinitializing it asks me what is the
username and let's select that it says
what is the project and let's select
that and do you want to configure a
default compute region and zone right
and I will just say Yes And basically
then it shows me different options which
we have here so there are too many
options here and then here we were
interested in Europe West 3 so let's
choose 21 right and then that basically
allows me to choose my region and my
zone so it also gives you some
specification so it says your project
default compute Zone has been set to
Europe West 3A you can change it by
running gcloud config set and you can
give a compute zone right so I can
always give these commands I can get
help information here so I can just say
gcloud config set and I can be
specifying the compute zone so I can say
compute slash Zone and I can give a Zone
I can say compute slash region and I can
give a region name if I would want to do
it or the easier ways like what I did
right now so you can basically do a
command gcloud in it and then basically
it allows you to change your
configuration or set default things here
you can all the times you can say gcloud
config unset to basically remove a
compute zone or a compute region now
there are different ways so if you were
working on a Linux machine you could
always use an export command something
like this so you could do export compute
sorry Cloud SDK and then you can say
compute underscore Zone and then give
your Zone name or compute underscore
region and give your region or you could
add it in your bashrc file right now
that is when you have your Cloud SDK set
up on your Linux machine or on Windows
machine and you would want to
specifically set a Zone and a region for
all your compute related resources so we
don't need to do that the default
settings are already given here right
and what we can do is we can start by
quickly looking into gcloud compute
instances options so I can say gcloud
compute instances and then I can just do
a list at any point of time if you would
need help you can just do a gcloud
compute and then say minus minus help or
I could just do a gcloud compute and
that shows me different options which I
I have here from which I use instances I
can always type instances and again hit
enter and it shows me different options
what you would want to do so I can
initially just type list which should
show me what are the list or what are
the instances available and as of now we
don't have any instances I can always do
a list and then I can specify minus
minus format and then try to get the
information in a Json format or EML or
minus minus format text
so you can always do a list you can do a
filter so there are different options
with your list and you can you can try
doing a help here and that basically
shows you what are the options so for
example if I do a help and it shows me
with list what are the things you can do
so you can give a name you can give a
regular expression you can say in
particular Zone you can use a minus
filter so there are different commands
which are available and you can always
find all those options here as I showed
you earlier so now what we would be
interested in is basically going for
your compute instances I can always do a
SSH and I can create an instance I can
add and remove metadata right for my
instances by giving a particular Zone by
giving a particular region and if you
would want to do that now here what we
can do is we can can basically create an
instance by just giving a name to that
particular instance and we can then go
back to our console and see what has it
done so I can say here create so that's
an option let's see what does the create
do so it says okay you are giving a
create option but you would have to give
a name so let's say let's call it E1 and
that will be the name of my instance and
this one is an easy command from your
Cloud cell which basically creates an
instance you see the Zone which has been
set it is the standard machine type it
is not preemptable it has an internal IP
and it has an external IP now I have
created an instance and here I can just
go back and then I can just do a Refresh
on this page and that already shows me
the instance which I've created and then
you can use the same method to connect
to it using an SSH so I have an instance
created from my cloud shell and what I
can do is I can basically look into
instances and see what are the different
options with instance so if we did a
create right you have an option delete
we did a create you have an option
delete you can be in deleting the
instance from the command line or you
can use other options so you can do a
list you can do a stop you can start so
I can basically do a stop and let's say
even let's go ahead and do a stop
commands are pretty easy here to
remember or you can always use the help
option and now I'm trying to stop the
instance and then basically I can go
ahead and delete it so this is a simple
way where I created a instance from the
command line or from the console which I
showed earlier and similarly you can be
working with other options so now I have
created stop the instance let's do a
listing to see if my instance shows up
it shows up right and it says the status
is terminated so you have stopped it
it's in the terminated status and now
what I can do is I can go ahead and
delete it
so it says this will be lost are you
sure you would want to continue just say
yes and that should take care of
deleting your instance
so this is a quick demo on creating your
instance we have already seen how you
can connect to these instances using SSH
now that we have created instances let's
also see how to use Google Cloud's
storage service which can be used to
load data or upload data so for this we
will have to look into your Google cloud
storage options and here you can look in
cloud storage so let's go back here on
the top which shows me different
Services which we have here and let's
look into storage so this one shows me
your storage option now you can click on
browser and that basically shows me your
storage browser which shows me on the
top you have options for creating a
bucket now Google Cloud Storage allows
you to store any kind of data here the
easiest and the simplest way would be by
using Cloud console although you can
again use cloud shell and in that you
can use your GS util command and GS util
basically has different options where
you can be using say for example I would
want to work on buckets so I can be
using MB and then I can use my command
line option to create buckets I can put
in data there I can browse it and I can
access the data from command light so
let's create a bucket here let's click
on this let's give it a name so let's
say my data important that's the name
now I can click on continue straight
away I can look into all of these
options if I'm interested in so you can
basically be looking at your monthly
cost estimate in the beginning now I can
click on continue or you can say choose
where to store your data and this one
shows you different options so you have
region specific click so let's also give
the bucket name with all lower case
that's what is required yeah so coming
back to the location type you can choose
multi-region which basically allows High
availability so your bucket or your
storage option will be accessible across
regions you can also give dual region
and high availability and low latency
across two regions I can also say region
specific so for our use case we can just
give region specific which can keep our
cost low but in business use cases you
would be going for multi-region now here
you have location and I would again go
for say Europe and let's choose Europe
Wesley Frankfurt it is always a good
practice that when you create your
instances when you create your storage
or you use different Services try to
have a geographical region Chosen and
then you would try to put things on your
services within the particular a region
within a particular Zone unless you
would want to make it accessible and
available across regions now I can then
choose a default storage class so when
you say default storage class there are
different storage class and each one is
for a different use case so you have
standard which is best for short-term
storage and frequently accessed data you
have near line so this is basically best
for backups and data access less than
once a month you can also have code
lines so these are basically like your
cold storage or freezing storage which
you might have heard generically as
terms so you can choose one of these
storage classes depending on what will
be the use case for this particular
storage bucket so let it be standard now
how to control access to objects so you
can basically say specify access to
individual objects by using object level
permissions now you can give permissions
to the bucket you can just say uniform
access to all objects in the bucket by
using only Bucket Level permissions so
you can choose that you can also into
advanced settings and here you can see
different ways in which you can have
configuration set up now you can also
have a retention policy to specify the
minimum duration where that this
bucket's object must be protected from
deletion and you can set a retention
policy will not get into all that we
will just first try creating a bucket so
just click on Create and that should
create your bucket wherein I have my
bucket now I can click on overview to
see the details what is the region which
region it belongs what is the storage
class anytime you can always click on
edit bucket and make some changes here
you can look at the permissions so
bucket uses fine grained access allowing
you to specify access to individual
objects and then you can basically look
at who has access to this so in my case
editors of the project they basically
are the bucket owners owners of project
viewers of the project right and you can
basically choose what kind of access you
need so for this you can always go into
cloud storage and then you can decide
what kind of access you would want to
give whether that's a storage admin it's
an object admin object Creator object
viewer and so on you can always look at
storage Legacy
and for any other services depending on
what apis you have enabled right you can
always control your permissions so right
now it is storage Legacy bucket reader
and that's fine and this one is bucket
owner and then might be I was using some
other services like data proc which uses
cloud storage and that's why I have
given data's proc service agent also so
these are some of the members you can
remove you can view by specific members
you can view by roles so what are the
different roles which have access to
this so it says storage Legacy bucket
owner there are two owners based on this
particular project so these are Auto
controlled but then you can add or
remove machines you can save storage
cost by adding a life cycle rule to
delete objects after the duration of
current retention policy so you can add
different policies and you can basically
control your bucket now my bucket is
already created right so so I can go
back and then I see my bucket is already
here I can click on this option and you
can anytime edit the bucket permissions
you can edit the labels the default
storage class you can just go ahead and
delete the bucket you can export it to
Cloud Pub sub so basically if you would
want to have the content from this
bucket being accessible in a message
queuing system you can go for Pub sub
you can process with Cloud functions and
you can scan with cloud data loss
prevention so there are different
options which are available we can
always select this bucket and delete it
now I can click on the bucket and that
basically shows me different ways in
which I can upload some data here so I
can just click on upload files and here
then I can choose some files so for
example I'll go in here I'll go into
data sets and I have different data sets
so for example let's choose this one
which is a CSV file and then I'm just
uploading this to my out storage right
it's as simple as this so you can drag
and drop your files or you can just
upload your files and my file is
uploaded here now I can basically edit
permissions for this one right so this
is in the bucket so anyone who has
access to this bucket can basically
download this file it can they can copy
move or rename this you can export it
and you can look at the permissions of
this file so let's look at edit
permissions and it says
for this project whoever is the owner it
has access I've also given a specific
user my Gmail ID and I've given access
so at any point of time you can just say
add item and then you can start giving
different kind of accesses so let's
click on cancel here now my data is
already uploaded into this particular
bucket and that's a simple usage of your
cloud storage now what we can also do is
I can basically select this and I can
delete it I can also create specific
folders and then basically load data
into it I can click on this one I can
just do a download and then I can
download it anywhere on my machine so
let's go to desktop and let's download
this file so we not only uploaded some
content in the bucket but we also
downloaded that in a different location
which will be accessible now what I
could have also done is I could have
created a folder here and I could have
specified say for example immediate
immediate data
okay and I'm clicking on this one so
that's my immediate data I can click on
this one and now I can upload my data
specifically to this particular folder
by using the same mechanism you can just
do upload file let's choose air
passengers let's do a open and my file
will be uploaded so you can always
choose what is the retention expiry date
for this one so as of now there is
nothing right but you can be deleted
objects can be deleted or modified until
there is a minimum duration you can
control all of that you can basically
download it right you can copy it and
you can move it and rename it so this is
a simple example where I created a
particular bucket right now if for
example you click on this transfer so it
says cloud storage data transfer
products have moved you can now find
storage transfer service on-premise data
and transfer Appliance in new data
transfer section right so you can always
go back
to cloud storage you can also look at
transfer options which are mainly when
you are using your on-premise service
and you would want to upload data in a
Google Cloud right so this is my bucket
here now I can go to Cloud console and
here what I can do is if I would be
interested in working so I can just say
GS util right and then we have for
example let's try a help okay and that
basically shows me my GS util now you
can always go to Quick Start GS util
tool and this is one more way wherein
basically you can do it from the command
line so working with buckets so you can
do a GS util MB minus B and then on a
particular Zone if you would be
interested in and then you can say GS
colon and give a name so my awesome
bucket this is how you will create a
bucket which will show you it is
creating a bucket and then basically you
can upload an image or some data from
internet you can just do a w get
download the file and then you can just
do a GS util copy command and that
basically will pick up the file from
your Cloud shell location put it in your
bucket once you have done that you can
always do a copy right so here you are
doing a copy from your local machine
that is your Cloud cell machine to your
bucket and you can do the reverse of
that that is you can do a copy and you
can point your bucket and the file and
download it to your desktops so you can
just download that using the command
line and you can copy the object to a
folder in the bucket so that is by
creating a particular folder and you are
pushing the file into a particular
bucket you can list the contents of a
bucket using LS and then give your
bucket name so GS colon so we can just
try this one to be simple and rest you
guys can try so so here you can just do
a GS util you can do a LS GS colon slash
slash and then I need to give my bucket
name so in my case the bucket name was
my data important so let's try that so
let's save my data important and I'm
trying to list the bucket and the
content it has right and then you have a
folder and then you can look into the
folder and look into the files so this
is a simple quick option wherein you can
use your Cloud cell you could be using
your Google Cloud SDK from your local
machine or you can be using Cloud
console to create a bucket upload some
data on it download the data see if the
data is accessible and that basically
shows you the power of cloud storage
where you can easily upload any kind of
data now what we can also do is as
you're using a free account or even a
paid account unless and until you would
want to keep the bucket you can select
it and you can just go ahead and delete
it so this will basically ask you to key
in the bucket name and let's say my data
important you need to confirm your
bucket name click on confirm and you
could have done that using gsutil and a
delete command from the command line
that is from cloud cell so we have now
created a bucket we have uploaded some
data into it we saw how you can download
it or create a folder and upload some
specific data into it and also you can
do the same thing using GS util tools
wherein you can list your bucket create
your buckets delete it create some
folders into it and do everything from
the command line so this is in simple
way you can use your gcp where either
you can spin up your machines or you can
use cloud storage to basically use a
storage or a easy to use instance on
Google Cloud platform welcome to this
tutorial about Google Cloud platform and
here we will learn about cloud computing
what is cloud computing what is gcp
that is your Google Cloud platform what
are the benefits of Google Cloud
platform and what are its different
Services a little bit about Google's
infrastructure a comparison of different
Cloud providers such as Google offering
gcp that is Google's Cloud platform
Amazon offering Amazon web services and
Microsoft which offers Azure we will
also learn about Domino's Pizza use case
and then have a quick demo on using some
of the services on gcp
before we begin let's understand why
cloud computing and it would be always
good to learn about cloud computing
based on a use case there are varied use
cases where organizations are adopting
or moving their Solutions or their
infrastructure into cloud or I can
simply say integrating with Cloud now
here is one use case Nina started a
company that relates to website
development
the challenges which Nina was facing
were low memory space whenever required
for processing or for any other kind of
application related work
high traffic to website that crashed it
and also less number of servers
now with these challenges she was then
referred to concept of cloud computing
and how that could benefit and help her
in solving her issues most of her issues
were solved when she started using cloud
computing and with cloud computing she
could increase her memory space as
required that is on demand control the
load to the website that is basically
load balancing and handling more
requests on the website or requests per
minute
buying servers at a lower price that is
scaling up or down based on the
requirement
when we talk about cloud computing cloud
computing is use of hardware and
software components which a cloud
provider offers as a service which can
be accessed over Network
cloud computing is use of these
resources which could be either
dedicated resources or coming from a
pool of resources which cloud provider
offers to deliver a service to clients
users can access these different
Services
applications files from any device which
can basically access Internet
cloud computing allows automatic
software integration
it allows backing up and restoring of
data
it basically offers unlimited storage
memory or computation capacity
it gives access to reliable sources
which usually the cloud provider
themselves are using for their use case
and it is a cost efficient model which
helps organizations to quickly integrate
or basically modernize their
infrastructure
cloud computing is usually used with ID
or within ID space wherein there are
five traits if there is a requirement of
resources as the business dynamically
changes or grows
so for this cloud computing offers
on-demand self-service
so users could be using on-demand
Computing resources
or memory resources storage Network and
so on provided by cloud provider and
also do a self-service
all this is possible using a simple
interface and users can be using
processing power storage Network as they
need and pay as they go so there is
least or no human intervention required
when it comes to projects which might
need scalable network access cloud
computing offers broad network access
that is accessing resources over Network
across geographical regions or what we
call as availability zones which might
be multiple sites within a particular
geographical region
Cloud providers also have what we call
as resource pooling so this basically
provides a huge pool of resources which
are shared and can be accessed by
customers at a lower cost now there
might be customers which are interested
in not sharing the resources and would
be interested in dedicated resources and
in this case cloud provider also have
soul tenant offerings which help such
customers
if an I.T business or any other business
needs rapid elasticity
then Cloud providers also have resources
which are offered which are elastic you
can get more resources rapidly as needed
and thus you can scale up and down think
of a gaming company which would be
interested in launching a new game and
they would have predicted a certain
number of users which would get onto the
portal playing the game and what happens
if the request per minute or if the
number of users who are joining in might
increase now in this case organization
would want an underlying solution which
handles this dynamism scales as needed
on demand and once the demand is done
scales down this is possible using a
cloud computing solution cloud computing
Solutions also include measured services
that is pay as you go model for the
usage or for the reservations which a
user or organization would have made for
resources offered by cloud computing so
when we talk about cloud computing one
of the questions which always arises is
why is this model so compelling why is
this so interesting for organizations or
users who would want to use one or many
services from cloud computing so first
wave of trend which brought storage
cloud computing was what we call as Colo
that is co-location
ID shops that have been using or
managing huge amount of data from
decades basically wanted to build
their infrastructures to handle their
business needs now instead of building
costlier data centers
they would rent space or share
facilities and this was being done by
organizations even in past
thus they would free up the capital for
other use cases now this was more of
user configured managed and maintained
by them later organizations started
thinking of virtualization
so that was again user configured but
provider managed and maintained so
components of a virtualized data center
matched that of a physical Data Center
and organizations would have virtual
devices separately managed from
underlying devices
then later came container based
architectures or basically automated
services so within Google services are
automatically provisioned and configured
letting your infrastructure scale on
demand there are various reasons why an
organization would think of integrating
with cloud or benefiting by using cloud
and thus
instantaneously reaping the benefits of
modernizing their infrastructure now few
famous Cloud providers are here so you
have Amazon which offers Amazon web
services and a huge list of services
which come in with this you have
Microsoft's Azure you have oracle's
Cloud you have saps Cloud Solutions gcp
which is offered by Google Salesforce
and so on there are many other small
players which are also providing
different Services which are cloud-based
or organizations which are partnering
with these main Cloud providers thus
offering cloud services to their
customers
when we talk about why Google Cloud
platform there are various reasons why
someone would choose Google Cloud
platform
gcp has better pricing compared to its
competitors
when it comes to Speed and Performance
it is very fast and increases the
performance of the project
live migration of apps and there are
huge number of solutions which I will
show you further in further screens
which help an organization to adopt to a
cloud platform and integrate with Cloud
platform or even completely migrate into
a cloud platform
none of Google's competitors provide
live migration of apps
when we talk about Big Data AI machine
learning kind of solutions gcp provides
a lot of innovative solutions in
comparison to other Cloud providers such
as AWS Azure and so on
so what is Google Cloud platform it is a
set of Cloud Computing Services provided
by Google that runs on the same
infrastructure that Google uses to and
for its end user products like YouTube
Gmail and so on
let's learn about benefits of Google
Cloud platform
such as high productivity
working from anywhere quick
collaboration high security
fewer data stored on vulnerable devices
reliable resources which can be used
across organization across geographical
regions across countries
very flexible which allows organizations
to scale up and down as the demand Rises
or as the demand declines and cost
effective solutions for various use
cases these are some of the benefits and
if we look into different Services which
Google Cloud platform offers
we could look into detailed benefits
which each service offers in a different
use case which basically helps
organizations working in different
domains handling different kind of small
mid or larger businesses and with
different business goals
when we talk about Google Cloud platform
Services here is a list of services or I
could say high level domains or
categories of services so you have
compute related Services you have
storage and database you have networking
Big Data developer tools identity and
Security Management Internet of Things
Cloud AI management tools and also data
transfer Solutions
when we talk about Google's
infrastructure Google has one of the
most powerful infrastructure in the
world the infrastructure is available in
two levels the physical and the abstract
layers you have physical infrastructure
and then you have the abstract
infrastructure
physical infrastructure consists of data
centers extensive development of high
efficiency backend data centers
you have a very strong backbone Network
which is used by Google itself and also
offered as services to customers via gcp
platform services so you have Global
messed redundant backbone Network points
of presence when we talk about Google it
has 110 plus Edge points of presence in
more than 200 countries and when we talk
about Edge caching Edge caching platform
at periphery of their Network so this is
what defines the physical infrastructure
of Google now there is much more to it
rather than just these four points when
we talk about abstract infrastructure
that is divided in global regions and
zones when we talk about Zone a zone is
roughly equivalent to a Data Center and
a single point of failure so you could
have your compute engine which is within
a zone or you could say computer engine
is a zonal resource you have regions
which are geographical areas which
contain multiple zones
so you could have a region for U.S
Central or Europe Central Europe West
and so on and within a region you would
have one or multiple zones and zones
basically would allow High availability
of resources
so you have Cloud load balancer as an
example which is regional resource then
you have global resources and they are
available and shared across the planet
so you have various global resources
such as Network which could be even your
IP addresses and so on
now let's do a quick comparison of AWS
West Azure West gcp and let's look at
what each cloud provider offers later we
will also look into different services
in detail when it comes to Google Cloud
platform what each service does
what you can benefit from which service
should you use in what case we will
learn about those in later slides
if I compare your different Cloud
providers
when we talk about Amazon
and its Cloud offerings that is Amazon
web services or AWS as we will know it
Amazon web services has 69 availability
zones within 22 geographical locations
and soon it will have 12 more in future
so this number keeps growing based on
the spread of the services which a
particular cloud provider offers here we
are talking about availability Zone
specific information when we talk about
Microsoft's Azure it has 54 regions
worldwide and is available in 140
countries across the globe
when we talk about Google Cloud Google
Cloud platform is available in 200 plus
countries across the globe
when we talk about virtual servers
Amazon's ec2 that is elastic compute
Cloud it is a web service which
basically helps to resize your compute
capacity where you can run your
application programs on a virtual
machine so using ec2 service you could
launch virtual instances that would have
any distribution of Linux Windows you
could have different specifications when
it comes to Ram or CPU cores or disk you
could also decide on what kind of
storage a particular instance should use
whether the storage should be local to
the instance or whether that should be a
elastic file system or even an object
storage
when it comes to Azure or Microsoft's
offering as your virtual machine that is
infrastructure as a service gives a user
the ability to deploy and manage a
virtual environment inside a virtual
Network on the cloud
and this virtual Network on the cloud
would be managed by cloud provider
Google cloud or the offerings from
Google Cloud platform that is gcp VM
instances enables users to build deploy
and manage virtual machines in order to
run different kind of workloads on the
cloud now when we talk about compute
engine here it would be good to discuss
a little bit more about compute engine
and what are the different options which
Google Cloud offers so when you talk
about your compute engine
you have scalable high performance
virtual machines
compute engine delivers configurable
virtual machines which run in Google's
data center with access to high
performance networking infrastructure
and block storage and you could select
VMS for your needs that could be general
purpose or workload optimized and when
we talk about workload optimized you
have predefined machines or you have
custom machine sizes you can integrate
compute with other Google cloud services
such as AI or ML and go for your data
analytics you have when we talk about
your gcp VM instances just to expand on
that you have general purpose instances
which we call as N2
which provide a balance between price
and performance and they are well suited
for most workloads including line of
business applications web servers and
databases
Google Cloud also offers compute
optimized instances which we call as C2
instances which offer consistent
high-end virtual CPU performance which
are good for AAA gaming Eda HPC and
other applications now when we talk
about compute optimize your general
purpose how would we leave memory
optimized instances those are M2
machines which Google offers so these
offer highest amount of memory these VMS
are well suited for in-memory databases
such as sap Hana real-time analytics and
in-memory caches so if I would summarize
this when we talk about different
instances AWS
also offers different kind of instances
which are memory or compute or disk
optimized you have general purpose and
each category of machines has a
different pricing model you can always
go to an AWS website look for the
pricing models and that will give you an
idea of on-demand instances or dedicated
instances reserved instances and so on
similarly if you talk about Google Cloud
Google Cloud also has instances with
various options which become the key
features of why customers would choose
Google Cloud platform such as live
migration for VMS so compute engine
within your gcp can live migrate between
host systems and when I say live migrate
it basically means without rebooting
which keeps your application running
even when the underlying host systems
require maintenance you also have
preemptable
virtual machines wherein you can run bad
jobs and fault tolerant workloads on
preemptable VMS to reduce your virtual
CPU and memory cost by up to 80 percent
while getting the same performance so
these are your preemptive or preemptable
virtual machines the only demonet is
these can give you a really cost
efficient resource usage however can be
taken off the shelf anytime and that's
why we call them preemptable virtual
machines you also have soul tenant nodes
which are physical compute engine
servers dedicated explicitly or
exclusively for users use case and when
we talk about Soul tenant nodes these
are usually good when you are dealing
with or when you're working with your
applications which we call as bring your
own license applications so Soul tenant
nodes give you access to same machine
types and virtual machine config options
as regular compute instances
so there are different options which
Google Cloud offers when it comes to
these instances which we are talking
about and it takes care of different use
cases in comparison to other Cloud
providers which are also offering these
services such as you can have predefined
machine types you can have custom
machine types preemptable VMS as I said
live migration of VMS you can use
persistent disks which could give you
durable high performance block storage
you have local ssds you also have GPU
accelerators which can be added to
accelerate computational intensive
workloads such as machine learning
simulation medical analysis and so on
and you have features such as Global
load balancing which makes Google Cloud
a unique choice
when we talk about platform as a service
Amazon has platform as a service
offering which we call as elastic bean
stock among one of its services it's an
orchestration service for deploying
applications and helping in maintaining
these applications
Azure cloud service provides a platform
to write the user application code
without worrying about the hardware
resources
Google app engine is a service used by
Developers for building and hosting
applications on Google's data centers
when we talk about serverless computing
so Amazon's AWS Lambda is a serverless
compute service it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required when we talk about Azure
you have something called as functions
which allow users to build applications
using serverless simple functions with a
programming language of their choice
when we talk about Google cloud gcp has
Cloud functions which is easiest way to
run your code in the cloud and it is
highly available and fault tolerant so
in these days when we are talking about
micro Services architecture which
organizations are preferring when we are
talking about organizations which can
scale which can dynamically change their
underlying architecture organizations
would be interested in serverless
Computing where they do not have to have
a infrastructure setup a planned in
advance before going for their use case
and this is where monolithic
applications are really not a Preferred
Choice
a lot of organizations are decomposing
their applications into micro Services
based on business capability or
decomposing based on subdomains we can
learn about microservices architecture
later but just to know that serverless
Computing which basically helps any
organization if for example if you have
a web application that receives
non-linear traffic and you cannot keep
an eye on your server always it would be
good to have someone to Auto scale your
application serverless is basically a
Computing model where cloud service
provider is responsible for managing the
piece of code without the developer
having to bother about infrastructure
setup management maintenance and so on
now when we talk about applications
being serverless or benefiting from
serverless Computing one of the key
things would be zero Administration so
deploying application without any
provisioning and management Auto scaling
capability that has let the service
provider worry about scaling the
application up and down you have
pay-per-use model which any customer
would want to benefit from that is pay
only for the resources that you have
used or that you are continuing to use
right shorten the time between idea
implementation and employment and this
is something which any organization
would want that you would want a faster
bring to the market solution timeline in
comparison to getting entangled with
deployment management and maintenance of
your underlying infrastructure when your
applications are facing a high demand so
when we talk about serverless
it is a function as a service
because each part of your application is
divided as functions and can be hosted
over multiple service providers you have
serverless apps which are usually
divided as separate units or functions
based on functionalities or domains and
so on so serverless Computing is getting
quite popularity these days in
comparison to the traditional three-tier
architecture where you had a
presentation layer you had an
application layer you have a database
layer now that kind of infrastructure is
not really preferred in today's modern
times when organizations are working on
different kind of newer applications
when we talk about object storage Amazon
has simple storage service that is S3 it
provides object storage which is built
for storing and recovering information
or data from anywhere over the internet
as your comes up with blob storage that
is binary large objects storage offers
large amount of storage and scalability
it stores the object in the tiers and
depending on how often the data is being
accessed now same thing applies to even
S3 which is from Amazon so S3 also has
different kind of storage classes which
can be selected when a user or
organization intends to use a storage
service and when I speak about storage
classes it basically means having a
frequent access storage or a infrequent
access storage or what we call as just
an archival solution
Google cloud has cloud storage and it
provides unified object storage for live
or archive data the service is used to
store and access data on gcp
infrastructure
when it comes to advantages Amazon web
services has Enterprise friendly
Services easy access to resources
increase in Speed and Agility and that
too on demand and takes care of your
security and reliability of resources
which are offered when it comes to Azure
it has better development operations
strong security profile provides a lot
of cost effective Solutions and
operation execution friendly
when we talk about Google Cloud one of
the key features here is better pricing
than competitors live migration of
virtual machines which really interests
a lot of organizations would want to
modernize their infrastructure without
having any kind of disruption in their
existing Services improved performance
redundant backups and so on
when it comes to disadvantages in AWS
you have limitations when it comes to
ec2 service well there are different
options in the kind of machines which
you can choose which you can work on you
have a technical support fee which is
incurred network connectivity and then
also downtime which might be in case
when you are migrating Azure it has
different code base for cloud and
premise platform is a service ecosystem
is not really as efficient as
infrastructure as a service poor
management of GUI and tools integrated
backup
when we talk about Google Cloud support
fee is quite Hefty it depends on what
kind of solution or support you would or
organization would be interested in it
has a complex pricing schema although it
has different use cases for which any
user or any organization can benefit
from downloading data from Google cloud
services is an expensive option storage
might not be however uploading data or
downloading data would be an expensive
option
when we talk about Domino's Pizza use
case now while we were discussing over
these features I would really want to
spend more time in discussing each of
these features or services in detail
such as you have compute engine you have
storage you have big table you have data
proc and so on so there are huge list of
services now before we get into your
Domino's Pizza use case let me show you
this page on Google Cloud where you can
look at different services so if you go
to cloud.google.com and if you look at
get started option under dock so here
you can find build Solutions look at
different use cases learn from basics of
what is your Google Cloud what are Cloud
Basics then you can look at different
Cloud products so here you have products
in different categories such as Ai and
machine learning API management compute
containers data analytics databases
developer tools and so on and you can
always click on
any one of these to look into different
solutions which are being offered what
are the different use cases what are the
best practices when it comes to
migrating VMS to compute engine or
operating containers or building
containers and so on you can always look
at featured products and that gives you
a quick snapshot of what are the
different products such as you have
compute engine you have Cloud run
bigquery which is a data warehouse you
have Cloud SQL which is a managed MySQL
or postgres you have cloud storage to
basically push in any kind of data there
you have security key enforcement Ai and
machine learning and so on so you have
different feature products now if you
scroll down
to the lower end of this page
you can again look at different
solutions and that would be really
interesting to read and learn from so
you have infrastructure modernization
you have application modernization you
have data management and so on so if I
look at
infrastructure modernization you could
basically look at the solutions which
Google Cloud offers and what it does
when it comes to having your
infrastructure modernized or benefiting
by integrating with cloud and having
immediate benefits of infrastructure
modernization you can look at different
use cases what they are doing how Google
Cloud really helps when it comes to
migrating the workloads to a cloud and
how your different Cloud Solutions such
as VM migration you have sap on Google
Cloud VMware as a service and so on and
you could learn from these different
solutions which are offered you can also
look at application modernization so not
only infrastructure modernization but
organizations would also be interested
in re-looking at their applications
really looking at how these applications
could be moved from monolithic to
microservices architecture or how
applications can benefit from
modernization and cloud computing
offerings so you have again different
use cases here
which talks about different ways in
which Google Cloud can help how you can
modernize your applications how you can
use different solutions which Google
cloud is offering now when we talk about
Cloud Computing Services you can always
go into
cloud.google.com if you have created a
free account then you can just log in
and every user by default gets a 300
free credit so wherein they can try out
different products where they can use
different services so here if I click on
Console where I'm already logged in with
my Gmail account or my Google Cloud
account wherein I have 300 free credit
out of which some is being used you have
a Google Cloud console and here from the
hamburger menu you can click and you can
look at different services within
different domains so you have compute
domain which has different services such
as app you have compute engine and that
basically allows you to use your VM
instances which we were talking about
previous slides different instance
groups create your templates use Soul
tenant nodes create snapshots or backup
of your data use different zones you can
go for kubernetes which is containerized
based engine you have Cloud functions
you have Cloud run and then you have
storage related different options such
as big table you have data store
firestore file store storage and so on
and for each of these Services you can
read about from the Google's
documentation or anyways I will be
explaining that later
you can also look at networking related
operation related and other tools which
are offered by Google Cloud so these are
huge list of services which Google Cloud
platform offers in different ways for
different use cases now let's look at
this Domino's Pizza use case and see
what it helps us learn about so you can
always access this page by going to this
link which talks about customers and
then which shows you different use cases
so Domino's increasing monthly Revenue
by six percent with Google analytics
premium Google tag manager and Google
bigquery
so this is basically when dominoes
started using gcp and what was the
result of that now let's look further
into this
so we all know that Domino is most
popular pizza delivery chain operating
across the globe but how was that
possible let's take a look so the
challenges were they wanted to integrate
marketing measurement across various
devices
connecting CRM and Digital Data to
create a clear view of customer Behavior
to make cross-channel marketing
performance analysis easy and efficient
now for these challenges which Domino's
was facing the solution was using Google
analytics premium
Google tag manager and bigquery which
were used to integrate Digital Data
sources and CRM data
reporting was made easier and more
efficient by implementing Google
analytics premium because it had the
ability to access a single Google
analytics account to evaluate web and
app performance
by using the new Google tag manager
implementation dominance were able to
act fast they were able to connect CRM
data with digital analytics which
basically provided Domino with greater
visibility on customer Behavior what was
the result there was an immediate six
percent increase in monthly Revenue 80
percent of costs in ad serving and
operations were saved
increases agility with streamline tag
management
they obtained easy access to powerful
reporting and customized dashboards now
that was just one simple use case before
we go on to Hands-On we can also talk a
little bit back about these Services
which Google Cloud offers as we
discussed and some of these Services
which can really make you think
why not Google Cloud platform so when we
talk about your different Cloud platform
Services let's learn about some of these
services in brief in what each service
is what it does and how it can help us
in handling our use cases or working
with different products so let's learn
briefly about different Services which
Google Cloud platform offers now one of
the domains is compute and then let's
look at the compute Services which gcp
offers now here I can log into the
console and this hamburger menu on the
top left corner I can click on this one
and go into the compute engine section
so this is the compute domain which has
app engine kubernetes engine Cloud fact
functions and Cloud run so these are
your different Services which are
offered within the compute domain and
here we can get into compute engine by
clicking on this one and then basically
going to VM instances so before we see
how we can use this compute engine let's
understand about some of the features of
compute engine which basically offer
scalable high performance virtual
machines which are configurable and
which runs in Google's data center with
access to high performance networking
infrastructure and block storage so from
here you can select VM for your needs
for your general purpose or workload
optimized predefined or custom machines
now here you can integrate compute with
other Google cloud services such as AI
ML and other data analytics Services you
have different machines which are
offered here such as general purpose
which provide a balance between price
and performance which are well suited
for most workloads including line of
business applications web services and
databases you also have compute optimize
based machines which offer consistent
high-end virtual CPU core performance
and which are mainly good for gaming Eda
High process Computing and other such
applications apart from general purpose
compute optimized you also have memory
optimized machines which offer highest
amount of memory and these VMS are
basically well suited for in-memory
databases such as sap Hana real-time
analytics and in-memory cache now we can
see these options here you can click on
VM instances while you are logged in
into your Google Cloud console here you
can even create an instance template
which can be used to spin up instances
for example if I click on new VM
instance from a template there are some
templates which I have already created
for my usage now here I can basically
use one of these templates or what I can
do is I can go back I can can go into
instance templates and this basically
allows me to create a template so you
can click on create instance template
which basically allows you to create
templates which can be used to spin up
different instances we can give a name
to the template for example we can say
template instance now here I can choose
machine configurations and this is where
you have different options so you have
general purpose as I mentioned which
provide a balance between price and
performance you have memory optimized
which are large memory machine types for
memory intensive workloads you also have
compute optimized which basically give
you high performance machine types for
compute intensive workloads so you can
choose any machine configuration which
is available here based on your
requirements now if you click on general
purpose that has different options here
so you look into the series where you
have N1 series you have E2 which is CPU
platform select based on availability
you have N2 and n2d so let's just have
N1 selected now you also have here which
talks about machine types and here we
can choose the configuration which we
are interested in depending on the
applications which will run within the
machines we can choose a machine so by
default it shows one virtual CPU core
and 3.5 gigabyte of memory or Ram you
could choose a higher end machine so as
of now I'll just say N1 standard now
that basically allows me to choose these
machines so there are different features
which your compute offers such as you
have live migration for VMS you have
preemptable virtual machines you have
sold tenant nodes and all those options
can be seen here now in this machine for
my boot disk I can select a distribution
which I would be interested in for
example I could be going for public
images and I can choose for example
Ubuntu and then I I can choose a version
so it shows me
16.04 and you also have latest version
such as Ubuntu 20. you can choose one of
these and here it asks you to choose the
boot disk type so that could be standard
persistent disk which is hdds which are
low in performance and you can say low
in cost in comparison to ssds so ssds
give you better performance but then
they are little expensive than using
standard persistent disk we can choose
this and we can give a disk size for
example 20 gigabyte and I can click on
select before clicking on select I can
click on custom images and that shows me
if you have any other images created in
your project you could use those you
could also learn about images by
clicking on this link so we'll click on
public images we have chosen this
distribution let's do a select and now
here you have identity and API access
management so let this be default you
you can say allow default access and
what you need is depending on the
services we can choose it allows HTTP
and https traffic now we would also need
some way to connect to these machines so
when you set up an instance by default
you can do SSH into it using the Google
Cloud console or from cloud shell you
can also give a private and a public key
so here you have the option where you
can give all these details so when it
comes to management it tells you would
you want to go for reservations and you
can say automatically use created
reservation you could also say no you
would not want to use a reservation you
can also set up or provide a startup
script which you would want to give
whenever your machines come up and here
you have the options of preemptability
so compute offers preemptable virtual
machines so that is mainly when you
would want to run bad jobs and fault
tolerant workloads on these machines and
you can benefit with a reduced cost for
your virtual CPU and memory by 80
percent so these are virtual machines
which would be lasting less than 24
hours now by default this is off and it
purely depends on your workload what you
would want to run on these instances I
could just go ahead and select
preemptable being on that and use this
feature of compute you also have on host
maintenance which talks about what would
be happening with this compute engine
instance so when compute engine performs
periodic infrastructure maintenance it
can migrate your VM instances to other
hardware and this is one of the features
which compute engine offers which we
call as live migration for VMS here your
compute engine can live migrate between
host systems that is the underlying
systems on which these VM instances are
based on without rebooting which will
keep your application running even when
whole system require maintenance and
here it says migrate VM instance
recommended and let that be as it is you
can also say that if there is a
maintenance happening you can terminate
the VM instance now it also talks about
automatic restart which is on which
basically means compute engine can
automatically restart VM instances if
they are terminated from non-user
initiated reasons so these are all the
settings which are available in
management and it also tells us the
different features which we have there
is also a feature called Soul tenancy
which basically means sold tenant sold
tenant nodes which can be chosen so you
can have physical compute engine servers
dedicated exclusively for your use and
this is usually good when you are
talking about bring your own license
applications so Soul tenant nodes give
you access to same machine types and VM
configuration options as a regular
compute instances however these might be
a little expensive we can choose this
one we can also look into networking
which basically shows the default setup
which goes for auto subnet you can also
choose a particular IP if that is
required but that would cost more you
can click on disks which talk about what
do you want to do with the boot disk
when the instance is deleted what is the
encryption mechanism you would want to
use and here finally you have security
so basically as I said you can SSH into
instance using the cloud console option
and you can also provide a public SSH
key so one way of doing that if you
intend to use an external SSH client
such as putty to connect you can create
a key so for example I can go into
puttygen and here I can say generate
just move my cursor over here and that
will create a key I can give a name to
this one so I'll say sdu will be
username I'll give a simple password
which I will used to login to this
machine and then I can save this private
key which will get saved so let's say
hdu new key and this gets saved in a DOT
PPK file which is usually used when you
use an external SSH client to connect so
save this one and that saves a PPK file
on your desktop what you can also do is
you can copy this public key content
from here and this is what we would want
to give in our instance here so so that
the public key gets stored on the
instance and private key is what we will
use to connect so once I paste it here
it resolves the name to htu and we have
given the public key now in certain
cases you may want to use a software
which uses SSH to connect to the machine
and that software might not be such as
your putty so in that case you may want
a pem file or a private key which is
saved as a DOT pem file so you can also
do that by going to conversions and do a
export openssh key and then save it so
I'll say hdu new key but then this one
will be saved as a pem file on my
machine so you have PPK file which
allows you to use putty to connect to
the instance you have a pen in case a
software needs directly SSH to these
machines you also have the public key
which we have already provided in the
machine now once this is done I can
close puttygen I can go back to this
page where I'm creating an instance
template and then I can just click on
create so this has created a instance
template which I can use to spin up my
instances any number of instances using
the same template only thing which I
would have to do is change the region
where I would want the instance to run
so now that we have created instance and
that's my this one the third option I
can go back to VM instances now I can
click on Create and here I can either
create an instance from scratch by
giving all the details again or I can
just use my template so I can click on
new VM instance from a template choose
my template click on continue and once
this is done I can give my instance name
so let's say C1 I can choose the region
so I will choose Frankfurt and then rest
everything is auto populated based on
the template what you have given and you
click on create now this basically
allows you to spin up an instance and
you can create any number of instances
using your template you could have
already created a new instance right
from scratch now once the instance is
created this has a public IP and a
private IP private IP will not change
unless you would want to set up a new
machine but public IP will change every
time you stop and start the machine now
this is what we need to connect to this
machine I can also do a SSH from here by
doing this in open in a browser window
let's click on this so this is an
internal way of connecting to your
instance using SSH let's wait because it
would be transferring the SSH keys to
the VM it establishes a connection and I
am connected to my machine what we can
easily do is to confirm if we are in the
right machine we can just do a LS to
look at the file system what we can also
do is we can basically log in as root by
doing a sudo Su and that allows you to
get into the machine as root and from
here I can switch to hdu user which will
have a DOT SSH directory in home and
that basically has authorized keys and
if we would want to see if this one
contains my public key I can just do a
cat dot SSH and then look into
authorized keys and this shows me the
public key which we had initially added
to our instance so this confirms that we
are logged into the machine which we
created now I can close this and what I
can also do is I can copy this public IP
so let's do a copy to clipboard now go
to putty and here I will say hostname
where I'll say hdu give my public key
I'll click on SSH and in SSH I'll go to
authentication now here we need to give
our PPK file so the PPK file was sdu new
key select this one come back here come
to the session give it a name for
example C1 save it and then you can just
say open and say yes and you are logged
in to your machine now once you are
logged in you can always do a minus SSH
and that shows you the file so this is
how you have just used the compute
engine to spin up an instance but we
used a template which basically allowed
me to create this instance and then I
can connect to this instance and then I
can start working on this so when we
talk about features of compute engine it
has predefined machine types as we saw
so compute engine offers different
predefined virtual machines and this
they have configurations for every need
from small general purpose instances to
large memory optimized instances with up
to 11.5 terabytes of ram you can have
fast compute instances optimized up to
60 virtual CPU cores you also have
custom machine types so you can create a
VM that best fits your workload and by
tailoring a custom machine type to your
specific need you can realize
significant savings there are
preemptable VMS which we saw there is
also a facility which allows you to take
the benefit of live migration for VMS
you have durable high performance block
storage for virtual machine instances in
the form of persistent disks where data
is stored redundantly for integrity
flexibility and to raise size storage
without interruption and you could be
choosing sdds or sdds for your instances
now you also have options such as GPU
accelerators so for example if I just
click on create instance and I can look
into that so here let the instance name
be instance 1 and what I would be
interested in looking at this one which
says CPU platform and GPU so CPU
platform configuration is permanent you
can also do add GPU so gpus can be added
to accelerate computationally intensive
workloads like machine learning
simulation medical analysis and virtual
workstation applications so you can add
and remove gpus to a VM when your
workload changes and pay for GPU only
while using so these are some of the
features which basically compute engine
offers and we already know that Google
bills in second level increments so we
only pay for the compute time now there
are different savings which are possible
so you have commitment savings which
basically means you can save up to 57
with a upfront cost per instance type
lock in you have container support so
you can basically run manage and
orchestrate Docker containers or compute
engine instances so here when we are
setting up our instances there is an
option which basically allows you to use
or deploy Docker images now that can be
done you can also benefit from sustained
use savings that is sustained use
discounts which are automatic discounts
for running compute engine resources for
significant portion of the billing month
you can create a reservation for VM
instance in a specific Zone which is
basically seen under your management
section here and you can ensure your
project has resources for future
increases in demand and if no longer
needed did delete the reservation so
these are some of the features of
compute engine what we have done is we
have created compute engine using the
console now you can go back you can also
do that using Cloud shell and you can
click on this one which activates Cloud
shell you could also have the cloud SDK
support on setup on your machine which
can be used now I can just open this in
a new window and from here I can start
giving commands if I would be interested
in setting up an instance from my
command line so here you have different
options now to begin with you can just
do a g cloud and just hit enter and that
will show you different options which
are available which can be used so you
have gcloud compute here which shows an
option to create and manipulate compute
engine resources now I can just do a
queue to quit I can do gcloud compute
and that basically will again and show
me different options which are available
if you would be interested in setting up
instances from the command line so here
I can say G Cloud compute and then go
for instances and if you do not know the
commands you can just hit enter that
will show you all the different options
which we have so here we have different
options such as list or create or start
or update for example I can just do a
list here to see what instances I have
and the instance which we just created
shows up here it says that a status is
running I can just stop this instance I
can delete this instance I can even
create an instance by using a create
command here and you can just do a
create help which will show you what are
the different options you can give so it
says instance name is what you need you
can choose an accelerator you can choose
the boot disk and various other options
so I can just say create and then I can
give a name for example C2 and once I
click on this one it says did you mean
Europe West 4 zone so it is asking me
for the region and the zone and I can
say yes and these settings are coming
from my default profile I can always
change those by changing the metadata so
now we have created an instance it says
running if we do a list again to see we
see two instances created one was in
Europe West 3 one was on Europe yes West
four both of them have internal and
external eyepiece now you can do a
describe to look at the different
options here so gcloud basically allows
you different commands which you can use
to work with your instance to create
instances to change the metadata if you
would want to change the region if you
would want to add a startup script all
those options are possible from the
command line which we can learn in
detail in later sessions so this is your
compute engine as a service now that we
have learned about the compute domain
and the compute Services which is
offered by gcp let's also learn about
storage and databases that's again
within the storage domain and the
services which are offered by Google
Cloud platform now you can go back to
console and here you can click on this
one and here you can just scroll down to
see what are the different options in
storage so you have options such as
bigtable you have data store firestore
file store you have SQL Based Services
you have storage which is object storage
and then you have other options which
are available so Google Cloud platform
offers different storage Based Services
out of which storage which is your
object storage is quite popular one
click on store storage and that
basically shows you an option which
talks about storage browser so this is
your Google Cloud's object storage so
when we talk about object storage it is
basically a storage where you could
store any kind of data and when we talk
about object storage it is a bunch of
bytes which we address wherein every
object will have a unique key these
unique keys are in the form of URL which
allows you to access the object so cloud
storage is comprised of what we call as
buckets which are used to store and hold
your storage objects the storage objects
are immutable and every change creates a
new version now you can also have
control access via IAM that is identity
access management or via Access Control
list so there is also an option called
object versioning which basically says
if it is on every time you try to store
the same object in new version of the
object would be created otherwise newer
options will override old one as we
cannot archive the old version so let's
see how we work with this object storage
so here you can click on create bucket
now once you click on create bucket it
needs a name so let's say test bucket
and here I can just give say number one
so that says this is the name of my
bucket now I can directly click on
continue or it would be good to look at
different options which are available
here so when you click on choose where
to store your data so it already gives
me an option it says the bucket name is
already taken so let me give it a unique
name so let's say test buck and let's
call it AUA so that should be unique now
here it says choose where to store your
data so this one gives you location type
so you can have region specific buckets
which give you lowest latency that is
fastest response time within a single
region however it does not make your
storage highly available you can make a
dual region which is basically allowing
your bucket or storage to be accessible
across regions you can also make it
multi-region which is highest
availability offered as of now we can
choose region specific and now it asks
you to choose a location now as always I
will choose
Frankfurt now I can click on continue
and rest all the rest let all the
storage options be default or you can
click on a default storage class now
that tells you based on your storage
class there are variant costs when it
comes to storing retrieving or doing any
kind of operations so you have a
standard option which says best for
short-term storage and frequently Access
Data you can also go for Cold Storage
such as nearline which is best for
backups and data access less than once a
month you can go for freezing storage
such as cold line best for disaster
recovery and data accessed less than
once a quarter or you can go for
archiving where the data is accessed
less than once a year let's go for
standard as of now and now you can
choose how to control access to objects
so you have fine grained or uniform let
it be fine grained wherein you can give
additional permissions at Bucket Level
using IAM or object level permissions
using access control list in advanced
settings you can choose the encryption
and you can also choose a retention
policy so a retention policy to specify
the minimum duration that this bucket's
objects must be protected from deletion
or modification after they are uploaded
you can always learn about this more by
clicking here now once I have chosen all
the relevant options I can click on
Create and that basically will create a
bucket by the name I have given I can
click on overview to basically see brief
details about my bucket such as region
what is the default storage class and it
also shows you the link URL which can be
used to access your bucket it also gives
you the link for GS util now GS util is
a command which can be used in your
Cloud shell to basically work with your
buckets you can click on permissions to
basically see what kind of permissions
are already in place and you can then
make changes you can basically add
members you can view by different roles
so for example here by default it shows
other services such as data proc or your
bucket owner or bucket reader related
permissions which have been already
granted now once I have looked at my
bucket I can start using it I can drag
and drop and push in files here so as of
now there are no live objects in my
object storage that is in my bucket what
I can do is I can click on upload files
and then I can choose a location from my
machine for example I'll go into data
sets and what I can do is I can choose
some of the files here in any format
let's choose CSV or text and just to
open so this one will basically upload
my data sets here now once I've uploaded
the files I can basically close this one
I can look into options here which says
edit permissions and edit metadata if
you would want to download it if you
would want to copy move or rename it if
you would want to export to a different
service called Cloud Pub sub which is
publish subscribing messaging system you
can scan the data now you can click on a
particular file and that basically shows
you the URL which basically allows you
to access this file you can try copying
this you can click on download and
download this file you can even try
accessing this from public and that
basically shows you the content of this
file based on the permissions so this is
basically your object storage which is
one of the service which is offered what
you can also do is you can create
folders and within folders you can then
upload your data so this is your Google
Cloud Storage option which is for your
object storage that is you can add
different items you can give different
permissions and you can use this Google
Cloud platforms storage service offering
now you also have other options such as
big table and we can go into that by
clicking here and click on big table so
big table is one of the service which
kickstarted no SQL databases today in
Market we see different nosql databases
such as Cassandra hbase mongodb couchdb
neo4j and many others so you can
basically use bigtable which was the
Pioneer when it comes to your no SQL
databases or not only SQL databases so
the problem initially faced by Google
was that the web indexes behind search
engine were taking too long to build so
company wanted to build database that
would provide real-time access to
petabytes of data and that's where
bigtable began so big table powers
different other Google services such as
Gmail Google Maps and other services and
in 2015 it was launched as a service for
customers so when it comes to
scalability with use of bigtable you can
increase your machine count without any
downtime and you can handle admin tasks
like upgrades restarts and so on which
are basically taken care by the cloud
provider data present in cloud bigtable
is encrypted and you can use IM roles to
specify access so data written to or
from bigtable is through data service
layers such as managed virtual machines
hbase res servers Java Services hbase
client and so on here if I would want to
use bigtable I can click on create
instance and that basically tells me
Cloud bigtable instance is a container
for your clusters now here you can give
an instance name so for example I will
say a u a and then say for example test
and let's say big table so that will be
the name of instance this will be
permanent you can choose the storage
type again you can go for lower latency
more rows red per second typically used
for real-time serving use cases or you
can go for sdds which have higher
latency for random reads good
performance on scans and typically used
for batch analytics so let's go for ssds
as of now here you have cluster ID which
is auto populated you can choose a
region so let's go for our favorite one
here where I can say Europe West 3 I can
choose a Zone here and I can then choose
how many nodes would I want to use for
my big table so when you talk about big
table service it will have a cluster
underlying which will have various nodes
which will Contour your data throughput
storage and rows read per second so as
of now let it be just one node and
that's enough for our demo when we talk
about performance it basically tells you
based on the current node and storage
type it tells you how many reads can
happen at milliseconds so it says ten
thousand rows per second at six
millisecond you have rights which are
ten thousand rows per second or you have
scans which are 220 megabytes per second
storage which is taken care here would
be 2.5 terabytes and I can then
basically click on create now there is
also some option called replication
guidance which basically says
replication for cloud table big table
copies your data across multiple regions
enabling you to isolate workload and
increase the availability and durability
of your data depending on your use case
you can have big table which can be used
to have your data across regions now you
can click on create with all your
specifications Chosen and that's going
to set up a cluster or you can say a
fully managed nosql database which will
give you low latency and replication for
high availability now once we have a new
instance you can connect to a it with
the CBD command line tool and for
instructions you can click on learn more
here you can just click on this instance
ID to see the details again if you would
want to look into your big table setup
so it tells me here that we have one
instance what is the CPU utilization
time how many rows for read or written
what is the throughput and this is auto
populated based on your usage you can
click on monitoring and that basically
will give you different widgets which
will display information for your CPU
utilization what is your hottest node
depending on how many nodes you have
system errors automatic failovers
storage utilization and so on you can
click on key visualizer which will allow
you to look into your table if you have
already created some data here and you
can click on tables to see how many
tables you have added here so that's in
brief about your big tables which is one
thing which we need to remember is it's
not good for all use cases so should be
used for low latency access that is fast
access and good if at least data is
greater than one terabyte for smaller
amount of data the overhead is too high
so big tables performance will suffer if
you store individual elements larger
than 10 megabytes if you want to store
bigger objects such as images video
files then go for object storage and
that would be a better option so always
remember bigtable is not a relational
database it's a nosql database and when
you talk about multi row transactions or
online transaction processing bigtable
is not the right choice so it can be
used for wide range of applications
especially when you talk about your olap
that is online analytical processing so
it is designed to store key value Pairs
and there can be different use cases so
for example if you are using something
like cloud data flow or cloud data proc
where you would want mapreduce kind of
operations bigtable can act as a good
storage because it has very high
throughput and scalability and the best
thing is that it supports hbase API thus
allowing easy integration with Apache
Hadoop and Spark clusters which you can
bring up using one more service which
Google Cloud platform offers which is
called cloud data proc so bigtable is
good for real-time analytics it's
commonly seen in financial services iot
and others and if you are thinking of
running interactive SQL then bigtable
would not be the right choice but the
other choice would be bigquery you
should also remember that this has a
cluster running and you would be charged
if this cluster kept on running so you
have have to be very careful in your
free account when you're using such
Services now we have clicked on this one
so I can select this one and basically I
can look at the permissions I can look
at the labels I can look at inherited
permissions here I can also click on my
instance
which we created and either you can edit
or you can just do a delete so as of now
we will just delete this which needs you
to given the name so we'll say AUA test
b t and then click on delete so whenever
you are trying out different Services
the first approach should be setting up
these different Services seeing how they
work basically trying connecting to them
and once you are satisfied with the
initial test then you can plan your
actions and come back and use the
service for a longer duration now that's
your big table which is one of the
offerings we can go back into storage
and here you have other options which
are available so for example we were in
big table you also have an option such
as cloud data store now that's one more
service which is offered by Google Cloud
platform when it comes to storage domain
so Google added software on top of big
table which supports more more than
simple key value pairs
when you talk about secondary indexes
instead of just having one primary index
when you talk about asset properties for
Reliable transactions such as SQL query
like language so these features or these
Services were added to or on top of your
big table which gave birth to a new
service which was released as cloud data
store so this is where you have cloud
data store and you can select a cloud
firestore mode so you can go for a
native mode enable all Cloud firestore's
features with offline support or you can
go for clouds data store system on top
of clouds firestore so these are
different options here and here we look
at the API or scalability engine support
how many rights it supports and so on
you can choose one of these and then you
can choose where to store your data so
for example if I click on this one then
it shows asks me to choose a location so
it says the location of your database
effect its cost availability and
durability choose a regional location
lower right latency lower cost or
multi-region location here I can
basically choose for example Europe
and then I can go ahead and create a
database so it says initializing Cloud 5
store in data store mode services in eu3
this usually takes a few minutes you'll
be redirected to your database once it
is ready so if we compare the pricing
structure between cloud data store and
Cloud bigtable always remember cloud
data store you pay for monthly storage
which is also in the case of bigtable
however here you are paying for monthly
storage for reads and writes but in case
of big table you are paying for cluster
when it is running so cloud data store
is a good option for small data
infrequent access and it acts cheaper
when you talk about large amount of data
or big data and frequent access then you
are talking about Cloud bigtable so
bigtable is cheaper when you talk about
larger amount of data so here it says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to cloud firestore in
Native mode to get more features you
could do that you could learn you could
say query by gql
as of now we don't have any data here
let's look at the dashboard which says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to Cloud file store in
Native mode to get more features so this
is your cloud data store and it has many
features
which help you to work with your data
however some features or important
features of rdbmss were still missing
and that's where Google created yet
another big table based service called
Cloud spanner now we can continue
working on cloud data store which
basically gives you one option to work
with your data
you can create an entity here by
clicking on create entity and that
basically gives you options such as
default namespace you can give a kind
you can give numeric ID and you can
start adding properties but to learn
more about datastore we will learn about
this in further session so as of now I
am going to click on cancel I am going
to go back to my data store and this
basically let's go to data store option
or I can go into admin here which
basically says if you have entities you
can import or export them so let's go
back and let's again look into storage
options so as of now we were in data
store let's click on this one so as I
mentioned your cloud data store which
basically gives you some additional
features on top of your big table but
what Google also did was it realized
that there was a need for rdbms feature
support that is there were a lot of
features now here we have created a data
store and it says your database is ready
to go just add data you can create
entity start putting in data and then
you can go ahead and query this so if
you would want to learn more about your
data store you can just click on this
one and that takes you to the complete
documentation of native mode and data
store mode what is firestore in Native
mode what is in data store mode what are
pricing and locations how you choose a
database mode what are the feature
comparisons what you can do what you are
allowed to do here what programming
languages can be used different regions
pricing and so on as of now we'll click
on this one and let's look at one
Advanced service which Google Cloud came
up with when it comes to your additional
features of rdbms so Google created yet
another big table based service called
Cloud spanner now that you might not see
here but if you scroll down you should
be able to see your Cloud spanner in the
options here or did we miss it on the
top so let's again look here here so it
is here and you can click on spanner so
Cloud spanner was released in 2017. it
basically supports relational schema so
it offers strong consistency for all
queries which can be SQL based you can
have multi-region deployment now when it
comes to massive scalability requirement
and strong consistency Cloud spanner is
a good option so it says Cloud spanner
is a managed Mission critical globally
consistent and scalable relational
database so if you would want to use
this then you will have to enable this
API which shows you an option here it
says try this API so it's a managed
service so it is one of the Google's
most expensive database Services there
is also one more database service which
is cloud SQL which can be used so when
we talk about your Cloud spanner it is
fully managed relational database
service it is massively distributed you
can have millions of machines across
hundreds of data centers with support
automatic sharding and synchronous
replication it gives you low latency and
schema updates without down time making
data High availability and reliability
so we learn about Cloud spanner with
more details later in other sessions now
we can also go back to storage and we
can look at the different options which
we have here so you have object storage
you have spanner you also have your SQL
based service which is yet another
manage service offered by cloud or
Google Cloud I would say so that's
called Cloud SQL so this is basically a
service which allows you to have fully
managed relational MySQL postgres and
SQL Server databases Google handles
replication patch management database
management and other things which are
related to this managed or fully managed
database service it can allow you to
handle terabytes of storage capacity
with 40
000 iops with huge amount of ram per
instance so you can click on create
instance here and then you can choose
one of the database which you would want
to use so Cloud SQL is a managed service
you can choose one of your MySQL or
postgres and SQL Server say for example
I choose MySQL now that basically tells
me what is the instance ID it sets up a
password you can always change the
password you can change the region you
can choose your database version and
then you can also look at other
configuration options which talk about
machine type which will be used what is
about your backup and Recovery
maintenance and all that and if you you
click on create this will basically
create a fully managed SQL service which
can allow you to straight away start
using MySQL on cloud thus allowing you
to store your relational data when we
talk about storage options how can we
not talk about a data warehouse solution
or basically an option which allows you
to run your queries by directly updating
data so you can use a data warehouse
service which Google Cloud platform
offers and that's called bigquery so
basically you can be looking into the
Big Data section here and here you have
an option called bigquery so this
basically brings ease of implementation
and speed so building your own data
warehouse can be expensive time
consuming and difficult to scale so with
bigquery you just load data and pay only
for what you use so it when it comes to
Features you have features such as
capability to process billions of rows
in seconds and if you would want to do
real-time analysis of streaming data
that is also possible here so here we
have clicked on bigquery which basically
shows you the option where you can start
typing your query and test your data
access for example if I have uploaded
some data so it shows me there are some
queries which are saved here now I can
schedule your query I can basically
choose the format of a particular query
by clicking on this more here I have an
option which says add data so I can pin
it to a particular project I can explore
public data sets I can create a
connection so if I click on explore
public data sets then it takes me to a
page from where you can get different
kind of data sets which are already
available which you can put into your
bigquery and start querying your data by
default it shows that it is aligned to
my project and I don't need to worry
about it I can look at saved queries if
I have already saved a particular query
I can look at job history I can look at
transfer scheduled queries and
reservations so bigquery basically
initially had its own version of SQL
which was slightly different from
standard SQL but in 2016 bigquery 2 was
released that supports SQL 2011 standard
you can always select standard SQL now
bigquery when it comes to pricing we
need to remember that the storage is
where the storage costs is very less
here approximately 0.02 cents per GB per
month it is almost similar to near line
where you can also have low cost that is
0.01 cents per gigabyte per month there
is no charge for reading data from
Storage when it comes to querying and
that's where the cost is incurred so one
terabyte per month is free and after
that it costs few cents per gigabyte so
this is mainly for high volume customers
there is a flat rate by pricing which
can be used so when you talk about
querying you can save your query results
you can create data set to store the
results now results are put in a temp
table in Cache and after you are done
with that you can delete data set and
delete all the data so when you talk
about loading data into bigquery you can
get the data from cloud storage Google
Drive cloud data store stackdriver stack
uh driver other options you have cloud
bigtable or other web interfaces so you
can download from URL such as CSV Json
Avro you can create data set create
table and create from Source by doing a
file upload so 10 megabyte or less files
can be uploaded using web interface as
an option you can also use command line
and then you can start working with your
bigquery so here you can also work with
streaming data by basically pushing in
streaming data into your bigquery which
allows you to add one record at a time
now you could use something like cloud
data flow which allows you to use a
particular pipeline about cloud data
flow we will learn later so you can
benefit from different features of
bigquery and thus use Google's offering
to work on your structured data or I
would say data which suits well in data
warehouses now these are some of the
storage related Services which Google
Cloud offers although we will learn
about using bigquery and running or
uploading some data by creating add data
set here by say creating connection or
using a public data set so as of now I
have this you can also access the
command line to work with this but we
will learn in detail about bigquery in
later sessions now here you can scroll
down and you also have an option within
Big Data space and that is your data
proc so when you talk about data proc
this is again a managed service which
allows you to run spark or Hadoop jobs
so especially if you are interested in
Big Data workload so for big data
processing for machine learning you can
always use cloud data proc this uses
compute engine instances under the hood
but takes care of management of these
instances so it's a it's a layer on top
to spin-off clusters it's a managed
service it's cheaper pay when the jobs
are running only it's fast because it is
integrated with other Google cloud
services you have open source components
pre-installed and data proc is
integrated with yarn to make cluster
management easier when you talk talk
about data proc you can click on create
cluster and that basically allows you to
set up your cluster by choosing a
particular region which you would want
to use for example I'll choose europest
4. here it tells what kind of machines
you would want to use and by default it
has populated as the machine here which
is 4 CPU and 15 gigabyte now since you
might be using a free account let's not
go for the high-end machine let's go for
N1 standard 2 and then you can scroll
down it says what is the primary disk
what is the disk type and this one was
for your master machine that is machine
which will have the master processors
running then you have your
worker node configuration which tells
this will be let's choose a lower end
machine and we can choose how many
worker nodes you would have so it says
minimum two you can choose the ssds and
their capacity it talks about yarn
course and yarn memory which will be
allocated and here we have then option
of clicking on create
so once you click on create this will
basically spin up a cluster wherein you
can straight away start submitting jobs
to this you can basically go ahead once
your cluster is ready you can go into
the cluster you can submit a job you can
choose a type which is spark or any
other application which you would want
to run and then basically you can use
this fully managed service which allows
you to run your big data clusters you
can obviously control access via roles
or Access Control list and you can have
access as it is at project level or
based on your data proc cluster or even
at your worker nodes so we'll learn
about data proc in later sessions so as
of now you see here the cluster is
getting created it says the cloud
storage bucket which it is using is this
one now I can click on this and open
link in a new tab it still takes me into
console but now it is showing me the
bucket which is being used by your data
proc cluster this is the bucket which is
being used and it is being used for an
underlying metadata which gets stored
here so you look at the cluster related
folders you can click in these folders
and then it can see what is the script
output what it is doing and so on now I
can come back here to my bucket which
will basically show me what kind of
buckets have been created so you see
data proc service automatically created
some buckets which will be holding some
data you also have some other buckets
which were created based on other
services which we used the access
control is fine grained in all cases
plus it also shows R bucket so
underlying it is using compute instances
it is basically using let's go here and
let's go to to compute engine and let's
look into VM instances
so data proc which has spun up a cluster
is also using the VM instances which we
see here are running it is using the
buckets and it has made a cluster ready
to use so you can click on this cluster
and that shows me my cluster related
details if there are any jobs running
what are VM instances what kind of
configurations it has used and you can
look at different details here you can
look at the logs you can click on jobs
and that will show you if you have
basically run a job on this ready to use
cluster so it says there is this
particular job which was run which was a
spark job you can click on submit and
this one tells you what is the job ID
what is the region you would choose for
example we will again choose for example
Europe West 4. it tells what is the job
type so you can run all these type of
jobs in this cluster such as Hadoop
spark Pi spark Hive Pig test row you can
give your jar file so if you have
packaged your application is a jar you
can mention that here you can pass in
some arguments you can also say some
other jar files add some properties and
then click on submit which will run your
job on this ready to use cluster now
since we have tested it I can basically
go ahead and do a delete I don't want to
incur any cost on these managed Services
which are running so there are a lot
more information about using these
Services which Google Cloud platform
offers and we can continue learning
about these Services as we explore your
Google Cloud console or even your
command line option now we can come out
of this one by clicking on this menu and
then we have other options such as
kubernetes you have Cloud functions you
have your networking related Services
monitoring related Services different
kind of tools what you have you have
other big data specific Services which
you can learn about and for each of
these servers Google has a very good
documentation available for example when
you talk about publish subscribed
messaging system it is a real-time
managed service which basically is a
Pioneer which was used and now you have
a famous service such as Kafka which is
being used for your published
subscribing or messaging system kind of
requirements
so to conclude about Google Cloud
platform Services you can always go to
cloud.google.com and look into the
document section now here you have list
of different featured products you also
have list of your different domains and
services which Google Cloud offers and
you can learn about all the different
Services which are offered by Google
Cloud here you can click on featured
products and that basically shows you
compute engine Cloud run cloud storage
you have Cloud SQL bigquery Vision AI
you can scroll down and look at your
artificial intelligence and machine
learning related Services platform and
accelerators API management
foreign
offers different services in mainly in
your compute storage and databases you
have networking related Services Big
Data specifics developer tools Cloud AI
identity and Security iot Management
tools API platform and so on so
basically learn about the gcp services
which Google Cloud platform offers and
in detail you can play around with
different Services which are offered by
creating a free account and as I
demonstrated you can use any one of
these Services quick start them
basically connect to them put in your
data or use a managed service to manage
your data and benefit from Google Cloud
platform thus having modernized
infrastructure for your different use
cases hi guys today we've got something
very special in stuff you you we're
going to talk about the best cloud
computing platform available Amazon web
services uh Rahul I think you said
something wrong here the best cloud
computing platform is obviously Google
Cloud platform no it isn't AWS is more
than 100 services that span a variety of
domains all right that Google Cloud
platform has cheaper instances what do
you have to say about that well I guess
there's only one place we can actually
discuss this a boxing ring so guys I'm
apeksha and I will be Google Cloud
platform and I'm Rahul I'll be AWS so
welcome to fight night this is AWS
versus gcp the winner will be chosen on
the basis of their origin and the
features they provide their performance
in the present day and comparing them on
the basis of pricing market share and
options the things they give you for
free and instance configuration now
first let's talk about AWS AWS was
launched in 2004 and is a cloud service
platform that helps businesses grow and
scale by providing them services in a
number of different domains these
domains include compute database storage
micro social networking and so on a very
important aspect about AWS is its years
of experience now AWS has been in the
market a lot longer than any other cloud
service platform which means they know
how businesses work and how they can
contribute to the business growing also
AWS is over 5.1 billion dollars of
Revenue in the last quarter this is a
clear indication of how much faith and
trust people have in AWS they occupy
more than 40 of the market which is a
significant chunk of the cloud computing
Market they have at least 100 services
that are available at the moment which
means just about every issue that you
have can be solved within AWS service
now that was great but now can we talk
about gcp I hope you know that gcp was
launched very recently 2011 and it is
already helping businesses significantly
with a suite of intelligence secure and
flexible Cloud Computing Services it
lets you build deploy and scale
applications websites services on the
same infrastructure as Google the
intuitive user experience that DCP
provides with dashboards results is way
better in all the aspects gcp has just
stepped in the market and it is already
offering a modest number of services and
the number is rapidly increasing and the
cost for a CPU instance or Regional
storage that JCP provides is a whole lot
cheaper and you also get a
multi-regional cloud storage now what do
you have to say on that I'm so glad you
asked let's look at present day in fact
let's look at the cloud market share of
the fourth quarter of 2017. this will
tell you once and for all that AWS is
the leader when it comes to cloud
computing Amazon web services
contributes 47 of the market share
others like Rackspace or Verizon cloud
contribute 36 Microsoft Azure
contributes 10 the Google Cloud platform
contributes four percent and IBM
software contributes three percent 47
percent of the market share is
contributed by AWS you need me to
convince you any more wait wait wait all
that is fine but we only started a few
years back and have already grown so
much in such a less span of time having
to heard the latest news our Revenue was
already a billion dollars per quarter
wait for a few more years and the world
shall see and AWS makes 5.3 billion
dollars per quarter it's going to take a
good long time before you can even get
close to us yes yes we'll see now let's
compare a few things for starters let's
compare price for AWS a compute instance
of two CPUs and 8 GB ram costs
approximately 68 US Dollars now a
computer instance is a virtual machine
in which you can specify what operating
system Ram or storage you want to have
for cloud storage it costs 2.3 cents per
GB per month with AWS you really want to
do that because gcp wins this hands down
let's take the same compute instance of
two CPUs with 8GB Ram it will cost
approximately 50 dollars per month with
gcp and as for my calculations that's a
25 annual cost reduction when compared
to AWS talking about cloud storage costs
it is only 2 cents per GB per month with
gcp what else do you want me to say
let's talk about market share and
options now AWS is the current market
leader when it comes to cloud computing
now as you remember we contribute at
least 47 of the entire market share AWS
also has at least 100 services available
at the moment which is a clear
indication of how well AWS understands
businesses and helps them grow yeah
that's true but you should also know
that gcp is steadily growing we have
over 60 services that are up and running
as you can see here and a lot more to
come it's only a matter of time when we
will have as many services as you do
many companies have already started
adopting TCP as their cloud service
provider now let's talk about things you
get for free with AWS you get access to
almost all the services for an entire
year with usage limits now these limits
include an early or by the minute basis
for example with Amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month you also have limits on
the number of requests to services for
example with AWS Lambda you have 1
million requests per month now after
these limits across you get charged
standard rates with gcp you get access
to all Cloud platform products like
Firebase the Google Maps API and so on
you also get 300 in credit to spend over
a 12 month period on all the cloud
platform products and interestingly
after the free trial ends you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account now there is also the
always free version for which you will
need an upgraded billing account here
you get to use a small instance for free
and 5 GB of cloud storage any usage
above this always free usage limits will
be automatically billed at standard
rates now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with AWS the largest
instances offered is of 128 CPUs and 4
tbs of ram now other than the on-demand
method like I mentioned before you can
also use spot instances now these are
for situations where your application is
more fault tolerant and can handle an
interruption now you pay for the spot
price which is effective at a particular
hour so these part prices do fluctuate
but are adjusted over a period of time
the last largest instance offered with
Google cloud is 160 CPUs and 3.75 TBS
Ram like spot instances of AWS Google
Cloud offers short-lived compute
instances suitable for back jobs and for
tolerant workloads they are called as
preemptable instances so these instances
are available at 80 percent off on
on-demand price hence they reduce your
compute engine costs significantly and
unlike AWS these come at a fixed price
Google Cloud platform is a lot more
flexible when it comes to instance
configuration you simply choose your CPU
and RAM combination of course you can
even create your own instance types this
way before we wrap it up let's compare
on some other things as well Telemetry
it's a process of automatically
collecting periodic measurements from
remote devices for example GPS gcp is
obviously better because they have
Superior Telemetry tools which help in
analyzing services and providing more
opportunities for improvement when it
comes to application support AWS is
obviously better since they have years
of experience under their bed AWS
provides the best support that can be
given to the customers containers are
better with gcp a container is a virtual
process running in user space as
kubernetes was originally developed by
Google gcp has full native support for
the tool other cloud services are just
fine-tuning away to provide kubernetes
as a service also the containers help
with abstracting applications from their
environment they originally run it the
applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment when it
comes to geographies AWS is better since
they have a head start of a few years
AWS in this span of time has been able
to cover a larger market share and
geographical locations now it's time for
the big decision so who's going to be
yeah who is it going to be gcp or AWS I
think I'm going to go for choosing the
right cloud computing platform is a
decision that's made on the basis of the
user or the organization's requirement
on that note I believe it's time for us
to wrap this video up we hope you you
guys enjoyed this video and learned
something new that AWS is better right
no that choosing a platform entirely
depends on you and your organization's
requirement hello everyone welcome to
this session on Google Cloud platform
website hosting and let's understand
what Google Cloud platform offers when
it comes to your web hosting
requirements
here we will learn about Google Cloud
web hosting some basics of cloud
computing web hosting service providers
what is gcp and why go for it different
types of web hosting which are possible
a use case such as Lush and a quick
Hands-On on using gcp for web hosting
when you talk about Cloud web hosting
Google cloud has the feature of hosting
a secure and reliable websites easily it
ensures customers and sites protection
the website is a is hosted on a fast and
reliable Network
you can do more work for Less Price with
Google Cloud
now when we talk about Google Cloud it
is always good to know some Basics over
cloud computing now when we talk about
cloud computing cloud computing is
basically using resources which are
provided by your cloud service provider
such as Google cloud and cloud computing
basically means using hardware and
software components to deliver a service
on a network now here users can access
files applications from any device that
can access Internet so when we talk
about cloud computing this is basically
using Services which are hosted on the
infrastructure managed by cloud provider
when we talk about resources which can
be used that may include big data
services storage options your Computing
options networking options and various
other services which a cloud provider
offers
cloud computing has various different
service models such as you have platform
as a service software as a service
infrastructure as a service also these
days we talk about containers as a
service and these are your different
Computing service models which are being
offered by cloud service providers which
allow you for automatic integration with
your existing environment or if you
would want to benefit from modernization
by using the cloud provider's
infrastructure
you have different Services which are
offered some of them are for auto
software integration or migration
backing up and restoring data scaling
your storage capacity that is going for
an unlimited storage capacity and using
a resource provided by cloud service
provider benefiting from reliability
cost efficiency which is offered by a
cloud provider in this case we are
talking about Google Cloud when you talk
about web hosting service providers
there are various web hosting service
providers you have AWS you have
Squarespace IBM Cloud GoDaddy Bluehost
and Google Cloud
so what is gcp and why go for it
when you talk about gcp or as we call it
as Google Cloud platform it is set of
Cloud Computing Services provided by
Google that runs on the same
infrastructure that Google uses for its
end user products like YouTube Gmail and
much more when you talk about gcp there
are various reasons why anyone would
choose it for their use cases now let's
look at some reasons when you talk about
pricing gcp has better pricing compared
to its competitors depending on the
services which you would use whether
that would be infrastructure as a
service such as using compute engine
instances and running your applications
on them or might be a managed service
such as data proc or bigtable or your
bigquery where you can have your Hadoop
clusters running or store huge amount of
data or even build your data warehouse
wherein you can store structured data so
there are different Services which gcp
offers and pricing has been a better
option in case of Google in comparison
to other competitors
when you talk about Speed and
Performance it's very fast and increases
the performance of your project if you
use different services offered by Google
when you talk about live migration of
apps this is one of the features which
organizations usually like which none of
other competitors are offering when it
comes to live migration of apps so there
are specific features for example when
you talk about compute engine there is a
feature stating live migration wherein
your resources or your instances which
are running applications would be
migrated during say maintenance from one
underlying host to another underlying
host without affecting your
application's performance and you can
benefit from that
when you talk about Big Data Google
cloud has various offerings in Big Data
space and that's one of the advantages
of gcp in comparison to other
competitors you have different services
for your big data needs such as Pub sub
for publish subscribing messaging system
or going for data proc which basically
allows you to spin up your Hadoop and
Spark clusters to run your different
jobs and so on so when we talk about
features of Google Cloud platform it
offers High productivity because you are
using the resources which are based on
the same infrastructure which Google
uses for its own different use cases you
can work from anywhere provided you have
internet connection and you can connect
to the cloud platform and use different
services offered via web you can quickly
collaborate with different teams or
different colleagues working on
different projects which might be
sharing or using the different GCB
resources you are benefiting from high
security and different encryption and
security mechanisms with gcp offers now
there are fewer sources or you could say
data which is stored or vulnerable
devices there is high reliability
flexibility or scalability which gcp
offers and the cost Effectiveness really
makes it as a good choice when you would
want to benefit from infrastructure
modernization and using a cloud platform
solution for your use case now when you
talk about different types of web
hosting Google Cloud offers three types
of web hosting you have WordPress now it
is a free and open source content
management system you might have used in
past or have heard about WordPress where
a lot of websites are being created it
is a popular web publishing platform to
easily set up blogs and websites and
thus used by organizations or even
individual users for having their blogs
or running their websites or promoting
their products you have lamp which
stands for Linux Apache MySQL and PHP
and Lam stack consists of Linux Apache
HTTP server MySQL and PHP and is used to
host websites and web applications
you also have your option of building
your own website so you can develop
website or web application with your own
code directly on compute engine now
let's look at a use case and understand
what happened here when we talk about
Lush so less was founded in 1995 it's
you might have seen this brand somewhere
in the streets it is a global Cosmetics
retailer headquartered in UK it sells a
diverse range of fresh handmade products
less had become a global brand with over
930 stores in 49 countries so the
challenges which were faced here was
traffic on boxing day caused website
crash for almost 18 hours and this is
something which had a devastating effect
on their business the previous platform
had no scalability option what was the
solution the movement of website during
the peak time was easy due to
flexibility of gcp platform with rapid
VM deployment on Google compute engine
the environments were monitored and
destroyed in minutes so the team could
test and deploy at speed by using Google
Cloud SQL lust took complete control of
its infrastructure and optimize its
systems for Effective scaling overall
the platform resulted in lower cost that
led to a bright future for Less
Cosmetics now what was the result of all
this the availability during Peak loads
was improved because of Google compute
engines Auto scaling feature the
infrastructure hosting costs were
reduced by 40 percent streamline data
center usage from 5 to 3 with Google's
high quality private Network really
benefited Lush and it provided a
flexible architecture and scalability
for future business growth now what we
have seen here is that your Google cloud
and its web hosting basically offers
user search to run their websites or use
a web hosting solution that can benefit
in more than one way the simplest
approach could be seen is by clicking
and setting up a VM instance by going to
your console for example if we go in to
the Google Cloud platform clicking on
console
and here the easiest way I could test it
is by going to my compute engine VM
instances and here I can spin up an
instance I can click on create now in my
previous sessions I have also explained
about how you could create a template
and run an instance from that we can
also click on new VM instance let's call
it new instance I will choose a region
for example Frankfurt I will let it be
general purpose machines let this
machine be one virtual CPU core and 3.75
gigabyte RAM if I'm looking for a
heavier website which might have more
users logging in and so on then I can
choose a higher configuration machine
here we have the option to choose our
distribution so for example I can choose
Ubuntu and then I can choose a
distribution version so it let it be
16.04 we can choose the disk size to be
20 gigabyte and we can use ssds or hdds
so as of now it is standard persistent
disk that is STD and that should be
enough let's click on select here I will
say allow default access I would say
allow HTTP and https so that if I have a
website content hosted on this machine I
can access it over HTTP now here you
have management options for your
instance you have security option which
basically allows you to provide a public
key if you are interested in using an
external SSH client to connect now I
have used puttygen and I have already
created a private key which is here I
have also converted that as a pem file
and anytime if I would want to use this
key all I need to do is click on
puttygen where I had earlier created
this PPK file now I can just do a load
and I can choose the key which I have
here
and I can give the pass face click on OK
and that shows you the public key let's
copy the public key from here let's go
into our instance and I can give this
here that resolves the name so I have
the private key saved on my machine and
public key which will be pushed into the
machine I can click on Create and that
should create my instance to which you
can connect using SSH from the console
itself or using a external client such
as putty which will then need the public
IP of this instance the PPK file what we
have and you can connect to this
instance what I can also do is I can
just do a simple SSH from here and that
will basically allow me to connect to
the instance what we also need to
remember is each instance what we create
in compute is also having some default
firewall rules now I have connected to
my instance I can click on sudo SU I can
log in as root and here if I would want
I can install a particular service so
let's say Apache let's say app get
install and then I can say Apache 2 or
httpd that is basically to host your web
application so I'm installing the
service
and here I can check if the service is
running by doing a service HTTP D status
or I can say service Apache 2 status
which says it is already running that
means the Apache web server page will be
accessible from HTTP provided my
firewall rules allow that now before we
look into this we can also for our
instance look at the firewall rules so
here you have Network details now since
we created an instance by default Google
has created some firewall rules which
allow default HTTP https
icmp your default internal access RDP
and SSH access and here it says these
Ingress rules which allow incoming
traffic are allowed from anywhere we can
customize that as specific IP addresses
we can also look at egress which is
basically outgoing traffic and this is
again saying my machine can connect to
the external World in different ways
using different protocols so you can
customize these firewall rules as of now
I am going to let it be default now be
connected to our instance from the
browser and we were basically checking
how you can use this browser by clicking
on this now what I can also do is here I
am logged into the instance my Apache
server is running so the best way to
check if the Apache web server is
accessible vhttp all I need is my public
IP so let's copy this let's go here and
I will say HTTP slash slash just give
your public IP and that shows your
Apache to web server page that means the
Apache service has already been run now
here it tells if you would want to host
a particular page what you will have to
do is as it says here it is based on
equivalent page on dbn from which Ubuntu
Apache packaging is derived if you can
read this page it means Apache HTTP
server is installed and this site is
working properly now you can replace
this file located at VAR
www.html
index.html before continuing to operate
your HTTP server so this is where you
can change the particular page and you
will be able to host your web site on
this particular ec2 instance what we can
do is we can can check this so we can go
into the browser and we can look in VAR
www and that has an HTML folder look
into this and as of now you have a index
dot HTML and that basically is the page
what we are seeing now I can click on
this one and I can see I have a small
HTML page which is basically showing me
what we are seeing on our web server
what I can also do is for now I can test
it out and I can put in a different HTML
page and see how that works so we had
basically the page here in VAR www and
then we had the HTML folder and in HTML
folder what I had was this index file so
as of now I just moved it and I put it
in a different location so if I look in
my home hdu
index.html that shows me the complete
HTML page what we were seeing on our web
server and here it shows you what this
page would display if you run it on your
HTTP it says Apache to Ubuntu default
page it shows it works it shows the
content and so on so for just testing I
move this page out from this location
and what I did was I added a different
page here so that page if you look in
HTML and then look in my page.html
section I've just added some basic
details of creating HTML I'm saying body
I'm using Marquee and then I'm closing
this with HTML tag now this is a simple
HTML page which I created
and now what I did was once I've done
this I basically did a service Apache
restart so once you do that it will take
up your new page
and once you have done that now you can
access that by going to your HTTP
given your details and then basically
give your public IP which we can get
from here
and just paste it here now hit on this
so that shows me there is a my page.html
I can click on this and that basically
shows the symbol page which I created so
as of now this is my web page which I've
created and this is hosted on my compute
instance now obviously we can create a
more complex website backed up by a
database use PHP use MySQL to store the
data and then host your website on a
Google Cloud platform service such as
compute where your actual code is
running so we can learn about your web
hosting on compute instances in further
sessions
are you in the analytics space Have you
ever wondered how data processing in the
cloud is changing the analytic space if
the answer is yes this is the course for
you all major corporations are moving
data infrastructure and Computing to the
cloud to optimize costs to make
analyzing data seamless technology
leaders like Google and Amazon are
investing heavily in SAS tools on the
cloud
Google is a Pioneer in this space the
Google big cloud data and machine
learning platform provides Cloud
databases managed Hadoop and Spark
services with tools like dataflow and
dataproc the platform allows for highly
scalable and reliable data processing
the data lab bigquery and Cloud machine
learning features make it a great choice
for business intelligence large-scale
analytics and machine learning
it's best in class performance and low
cost makes Google Cloud popular and
sought after
technology giants like Spotify and apple
have implemented the Google Cloud
platform at their organizations and
Healthcare and consumer goods leaders
like Philips and Coca-Cola are migrating
to Google Cloud for their data analytics
needs a Google data engineer with
expertise in Google Cloud machine
learning and bigquery earned 102 000 per
year on average and the demand for
Google data engineer certifications has
never been higher
simply learns Google Cloud platform big
data and machine learning fundamentals
or cpv100 course offers a thorough
overview of the Google Cloud platform
covering its data processing
capabilities with various use case
studies
it's the perfect course for data
analysts business analysts and data
scientists with real world experience in
querying
ETL data modeling or machine learning
it decision makers evaluating the Google
Cloud platform have also found the
training very useful
the course will cover everything you
need to know about the Google Cloud
platform and includes eight hours of
instructor-led training
modules on big data and machine learning
with the Google Cloud
hi my name is Randolph kale and I'm the
co-author of the Google Cloud platform
certification courses for Google
I'm certified on the Google Cloud
platform an authorized Google instructor
and the course advisor at simply learn
I have over 40 years experience in the
industry spanning different roles from
development managing Cloud
infrastructure to product management
I've partnered with simply learn to
ensure that you have the best
opportunity to become certified in
various Google Cloud platform
Technologies gain hands-on experience on
the cloud and make your job ready
before we discuss the course and the
reasons it will help you let me first
introduce you to Google Cloud platform
when you use the Google Cloud platform
you are empowered to build test and
deploy applications at Google scale
the move to the cloud is happening today
there is a broad industry adoption when
I teach classes I see the pace
accelerating across all companies Forbes
projects a 19 growth rate to 140 billion
US Dollars on cloud services by 2019.
how can you move to the cloud how can
you make a career in this fast-growing
part of the industry your first step is
establishing your credentials in the
Google Cloud platform domain and you can
do that by getting certified
the Google Cloud platform fundamentals
course introduces you to the Google
Cloud platform and shows you how you can
incorporate cloud-based Solutions into
your business strategies the course is
intended for solution developers system
operation professionals and solution
Architects planning to deploy
applications and create application
environments on the Google Cloud
platform
it is also appropriate for executives
and business decision makers evaluating
the potential of Google Cloud platform
to address their business needs
completing this course will give you the
skills and the confidence to take full
advantage of the Google Cloud platform
ecosystem
simply learn offers you extensive
training to help you understand the
platform
you get eight hours of interactive
instructor-led live online sessions
along with a course you receive a free
trial account with 300 credit toward the
use of Google Cloud platform for 60 days
the instructors are Google authorized
trainers the content is engaging and all
the topics are very well explained with
simply learn you'll be enrolling for the
online classroom plexipass which gives
you the flexibility to attend any of the
weekday and weekend batches according to
your convenience
another thing that's impressive is the
proactive teaching assistants where
experts resolve all your course related
project related or technical questions
while pursuing a course so if you're
looking for the training and guidance
you need to have a deeper understanding
about Google Cloud platform products and
services this is the best course for you
course material labs and authorized
instructors with extensive experience
I don't think you'll need to go anywhere
else take charge of your career sign up
for simplylearn cp100a training all the
best to you I'm with that we have come
to the end of this video on Google Cloud
in-depth tutorial 2022. I hope you found
it useful and entertaining please ask
away any questions you have concerning
the topics covered in this video in the
comment section below our experts will
assist you in the addressing your
problems thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here